there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
how the damn ice back we're getting
something out of it this drink so much
[ __ ] ice man every time I come and
hear the [ __ ] ice makers [ __ ]
halfway empty and the show starts and I
try to make two drinks no ice then it's
an end to [ __ ] I know you filled it
right now so she's like Mom out of ice
and I said I'll go there and he said
well we got to do the show should have
said something but I know I just used I
could have gone downstairs and [ __ ]
stole a bunch of ice down there out of
the other ice maker I'm stole it out of
her did you see them for one let me tell
my [ __ ] story and then and then I'm
pissed off because the [ __ ] sky is
falling out there just raining better
now I mean like half an hour ago I was
worried because the power winked off and
it was so loud I mean it was just like
the Thunder and I thought it sounded
like a tornado outside and then then I'm
[ __ ] mowing today I mow the [ __ ] out
of this place it was almost an acre it's
just point it's
0.99 Acres just they [ __ ] me by have
[ __ ] just a few feet so I don't have
a full acre here I can't shoot here but
[ __ ] they
was out Mowing and hit a sprinkler and
[ __ ] up one of the big [ __ ] 20
[ __ ] sprinkler [ __ ] that up oh you
didn't tell me that yeah
and then I gotta do that Gotta Go Gotta
Go to Lowe's tomorrow and get a [ __ ]
little sprinkler [ __ ] thing look it's
[ __ ] coming down and then
dishwasher broke
on warranty but dishwasher's broken yeah
I mean that's a new dishwasher because
when we moved into the house when like
before we bought it when we were still
renting it from the owners the
dishwasher that was in here we moved in
didn't work they gave us a new one so
they bought us a new one and I bought
the house got a free window and then we
bought the house that's right and that
that was only like six or seven months
ago so there's no way that that
dishwasher should be broken already it
turns on it's got power it fills up with
water the water gets hot it even drops
the soap the cycle never starts
I can I can press clear and it'll the
water will drain out
and then I can start it again and I
don't see any clogs or anything I don't
[ __ ] know what it is I don't know
either
what's weird though you know what
what it fills up with water and the
water's got a little
particles of [ __ ] food in it there
must be it's just probably just cloth
there must be a clog It's gotta be it's
not in the machine that happened there
are one at the old house yeah it's not
in the machine though in the machine
there's no so it must be something like
that yeah it's probably just like the
pipes it's draining and it's filling but
there's something wrong somewhere
Camp guy says don't chew up ice I don't
it's not it's not so much that it's that
I go through a lot of ice because it's
Florida and I don't like no [ __ ] room
temperature water or room temperature uh
sugar-free tea which is the only things
I drink during the day and I get really
really thirsty I always have to have
like a big huge like this size of water
or tea at all times and it has to have a
whole [ __ ] ton of ice in it because it
has to be cold but the thing about it is
that you leave it there and then like
after like 10-15 minutes the ice starts
to melt because even though the AC is on
it's still Florida and it's still kind
of warm so I [ __ ] went to Sam's and
bought a [ __ ] ice maker for upstairs
it's a [ __ ] badass little hundred
dollar Ice make you put water in it and
you got to clean that thing Man it gets
Brown in there the [ __ ] sediment from
the water but it's easy to clean though
but you had to clean the inside of that
damn ice maker
even if you're using filtered water I
[ __ ] filter the water and everything
it doesn't matter you got a filter and
then I ran I ran some [ __ ] um in the
water I put some uh water Army water
purification tablets in there oh did you
yeah you didn't tell me that either yeah
well I ran it through and we drank it
it's okay though and run it next time
man I put it in a canteen drip three or
four of them [ __ ] things you're just
putting things in my Waters yeah yeah
man we used to [ __ ] wake up in the
middle of the night and [ __ ] over our
friends and [ __ ] [ __ ] pissing their
cantines
man where the hell Runs put a water
purification tablet in there [ __ ]
you're not [ __ ] positions
why would you do that to somebody just
to [ __ ] with their minds it was a
[ __ ] tough man competition oh it
happened to everybody that's gross what
happened to everybody we just do all
kinds of [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's gross
like man somebody pissing this canteen
didn't it maybe people giggling and [ __ ]
you [ __ ] man if you did that to
me I be like well I have to throw that
canteen away now you really nice because
it's like I'm not you're in the field
that's what I mean no you got to be
[ __ ] hard you gotta go [ __ ] y'all and
just fill it right get back with water
like it did like like it's nothing
that's gross I'm like drinking other
people dudes are [ __ ] gross that's
why all those things that's what I said
women in the Infantry I was like oh
that's gonna go bad that's gonna go real
bad because [ __ ] that's like letting
them into a foot but you know who
they're nobody's nobody's joining now so
but back in our day that'd be like
that would be like sending [ __ ]
females into a Maximum Security Prison
that was also a [ __ ] fraternity house
it's just it would be it wouldn't be
dangerous to him it'd just be miserable
to him it would be miserable well it
would probably be miserable and
dangerous at times yeah depending on who
they are who it is but uh granther says
Bauhaus canceled their U.S fall tour
today bummed honestly uh I probably
would have been if I had known that they
were doing that and if I could afford to
have gone which I can't but I mean I saw
them like back in the late 90s I want to
see Peter Murphy and I saw Peter Murphy
a [ __ ] ton of time starting in 1990.
it's not the Peter Murphy we know that
grew up with he's changed a lot the
drugs [ __ ] him up and he's just
[ __ ] crazy man I still like the other
guys he's [ __ ] crazy yeah the other
guys are nice but they they canceled
that [ __ ] because they can't get him
under control I wonder if that's what it
is or if there's another reason I mean
of course I imagine that was just the
first thing that my mind went he would
get [ __ ] up and throw [ __ ] full
bottles of booze at the [ __ ] crowd
over in Scandinavian and [ __ ] [ __ ] he
get kicked out of his own [ __ ]
shows that threw his ass out like a
[ __ ] bomb he's a bomb he he did some
hit and runs
he'd be here that was here in Florida he
did the hit and run huh wouldn't it
it's all messed out messed out and
[ __ ] it was I don't was it a hit and
run yeah yeah [ __ ] right it was a hit
was it Florida
but I
it was a long time [ __ ] hit another
car and then [ __ ] ran
he left the car there and then they
found the meth in the back seat he's
like and he was like it's not mine yeah
that's what they all say yeah they said
his ass a drug rehab that's what they
all say
Zach says I feel like I burn hotter than
the average person in the summer I'll
take a can of soda and just press it
against my feet and belly for a few and
get some ice for you
the office as you can see I have my
little hoodie on because actually in the
office it's cold in here but
honestly I have to have like a I have to
have like a full thing of ice and then
pour the water over I have a whole like
situation that I have to do
um because I don't like room temperature
water I don't like room temperature
drinks of any kind uh that [ __ ] has to
be ice [ __ ] cold ice cold what makes
a [ __ ] ton of ice fast that ice was
[ __ ] hot I poured water in it like 45
minutes ago yeah and I and I read it we
have like and then we have a Brita yeah
so I have to fill so I fill up the Brita
but it takes like two goes I was taking
ice out of it oh okay uh because that's
what this came from but um and and then
I emptied the ice to fill these two
things up that was only 15 minutes it
was half full so it fills up about
halfway in 15 minutes 10-15 minutes yeah
it makes ice fast but you know I need to
get another one and now's the chance to
get a red one
he should have got the goddamn but I got
the red one why didn't you you could
just put one in here for you yeah you
just sit here and [ __ ] when I can
afford it I'm I'm thinking about turning
that little area like more because
there's a coffee pot over there already
and I'm thinking about turning that
maybe into a little kitchen area like
putting a little toaster oven yeah
little mini microwaves in here and work
and make yourself a snack and then yeah
I mean the thing about it I can make
myself eater I can make my well yeah you
do but I'm just saying like I can make
myself snacks but I can only make myself
snacks that you add water to because I
can heat water up in the coffee pot so
it'd be something like oatmeal or like
little like pot noodle things or
something like that it's it's things
like that all right just add hot water
too they're all pouring in here it's
almost about time to [ __ ] start the
show
um this is a [ __ ] bad one toolbox
murder is [ __ ] this bummed me out
crazy [ __ ] in the van abducting
girls out in California in the 70s
torturing them and killing them raping
them this is [ __ ] up and and that's
saying something I mean like all the
like all the True Crime cases that
they're all [ __ ] up it's not like an
Olympics or anything where it's like a
competition but for some reason this one
this one got to me this one really
really bothered me and the thing about
it is that the weird thing about this
case is that yeah like people that are
really into True Crime like sick
[ __ ] like me like have heard
about the toolbox kill toolbox Killers
but I feel like they're not that well
known like their names aren't that well
known yeah even though the [ __ ] they did
was just horrific yeah I mean it's it's
horrible it's horrible Graham says that
there's a filter in the bottom of
dishwasher it might be clogged yeah I
checked it that happened to the old we
saw our old one I opened all that up and
put my hand in there and feeling around
I don't feel any clog
so I don't know what it is maybe it's in
a pipe somewhere well like I said at
least it's still but it's draining it's
draining and it's filling so I don't
know how there could be a clog it's
filling and it's draining we're gonna
have to call a [ __ ]
Hugo said Jenny get a popcorn maker I'm
well I could I'm not super into popcorn
I'm not into popcorn I like popcorn but
I'm not into popcorn enough to get a
popcorn to pay to get a popcorn if I had
some [ __ ] up in here besides stand up
classic arcade games if I had any
machine up here it would be a it would
be like a [ __ ] Coke machine a real
one yeah somebody said get a vending
machine I love them that'd be kind of
neat I just I don't but honestly I've
talked about like struggles with weight
issues and stuff like that I really
don't need to keep candy or snacks and
[ __ ] like that in the house because I
will absolutely eat them I just love
going up to a Coke machine pressing a
button have to fall out I just I like
that I like that uh that sensation I
mean I like that too yeah it's like oh I
want a Twix bar yeah I want a Pop Tart I
want to I want a zero bar I'm the weirdo
that eats this I've seen those things
abandoned before
and like abandoned you could probably
get one for probably cheap well yeah
like when a business closes that happens
yeah they'll probably like just either
let you have it or just like sell it to
you for a super cinnamon of cinnamon
[ __ ] abandoned like [ __ ] motels
up in the main office you know those
Urban exploration people that go there
and there's like a [ __ ] 20 year old
[ __ ] 30 year old
machine that you know it's good
it's got to be good
you know or it should be
I don't know maybe we might have to
[ __ ] put new coolant in it but
everything else is working you know it'd
probably work yeah [ __ ] up with just
you know you could probably take it
nobody'd say anything
Well yeah if it's just sitting there
it's just sitting I just feel like the
whole thing I mean just a snack vending
machine would probably be easier to deal
with because it doesn't have the cooling
elements yeah but like I said I don't
want it like the idea is neat but I
don't really want to have like a whole
vending machine full of yummy like Twix
bars and [ __ ] like that in here because
then I need to eat them and then I'd be
400 pounds and then yeah then where
would we be we're both trying to [ __ ]
lose some fat I'm looking good I posted
some videos you guys saw it you post
some [ __ ] on YouTube too on YouTube also
are you being naked on YouTube no not
naked just [ __ ] shirtless [ __ ]
looking good it's coming along got a few
more pounds of fat to lose and I got a
[ __ ] new cycle coming up here in a
[ __ ] couple days
I'm gonna start a new one but I can see
what it is [ __ ] Wicked we'll see
what's going to happen I might I'm still
not done with some win straw that I was
[ __ ] given by the doctor
and then uh
I got the Holy Grail coming of of all
that [ __ ] and that will burn pretty much
every ounce of fat off you
but I got to be careful with that [ __ ]
because it [ __ ] it's got a reputation
of making a [ __ ] psychopathic so
I got a great that's all yeah so uh I'm
gonna [ __ ] am I gonna have to get
like a taser or something yeah we're
gonna have to [ __ ] you had to walk
around with a pistol on [ __ ] uh it'd
probably be all right can I get it I'll
get a bang stick I like for sharks I've
talked to guys and then I'll just go
I've talked to guys that I've known
knock it out I've talked to guys I've
talked to guys that I trust that have
done it [ __ ] uh and that they did it
and it they said that was nowhere near
as bad as they thought it was just like
yeah but it's like I live with you so
we'll see well I'm gonna I'm gonna get a
taser the thing about it the thing about
this one is that they're all about the
same price per CC but this is so
powerful you use so little of it it's
very [ __ ] cost effective because the
doses the dosages are tiny but it get a
lot of bang for the buck we'll see we'll
see
I'm just gonna try it if I act [ __ ]
crazy I'll come off of it are you gonna
get mad if I have to like knock you in
the head or something
like if you start like acting I'm going
to kill her I'm going into this [ __ ]
with a proper mindset
so if I if so if I start
if I start [ __ ] acting strange I say
well it's not me it's this [ __ ] I'm
dubious I'm dubious they say you feel
like a god though on this [ __ ] like you
need that yeah
why do you take this [ __ ] you're bad
enough as it is without all the other
stuff God damn
I got some [ __ ] physical [ __ ] I want
to get done I wanna [ __ ] it's part of
the rebuild process it's HRT hormone
replacement therapy anti-aging therapies
all right it's anti-aging therapy so I'm
gonna not have a fun time for those two
months is what you're saying
um Tom calendar win wait it's about
about the time when all the gay porn
starts coming out
I already got I already got yeah why
don't you channel the [ __ ] into some gay
porn
you could shoot it in the other shoot it
in the Next Room
decorate it in there you can do it it's
just gonna change Solo or is it gonna be
Solo or Channel it into that who am I
gonna be working with well I don't know
anybody who would like it's gay porn so
you you know
just
have have an outlet right I'm all right
all right hurricane guard says I've seen
a documentary about these about these
[ __ ] oh God at least they got
caught because very stupid reasons yeah
uh showed they were both monsters and
dumbasses I mean the thing about it like
one of them
uh Lawrence bitticker I think was
actually uh almost a genius but
he actually ended up getting caught more
because his other like the partner was a
dumbass but it was just kind of the
thing I don't know I kind of wish that
they honestly it's not only that I wish
they'd been caught earlier I wish both
of them had been aborted okay I wish
both of them had been aborted because
the thing about it is that both of them
separately they didn't meet each other
until later on
this is one of those serial killer
couple situations where now I'm sure
that
we've talked about serial killer couples
before and I'm kind of like fascinated
about oh if this person hadn't met this
person like would all of this [ __ ] have
happened now these two [ __ ] I'm
not sure about one of them but I think
one of them absolutely would have
probably been a serial killer on his own
um not so sure about the other one but
he was a piece of [ __ ] too like I don't
know if he's a serial killer but he
wouldn't have been like an upstanding
citizen or anything but these two
um separately pretty much both of their
families like when they were born
because they were both born in like the
40s and neither of their parents
particularly wanted them and I kind of
feel like I think the world would have
been a better place if they had been
aborted like both of them I'm just
saying that no that's true it's true
um you know but you couldn't really do
that in the 40s sadly so
yeah you know well there's a lot of
people that probably fit that same bill
that's not enough to make you do serial
killer [ __ ] these [ __ ] are
crazy
yeah and
and we talk about that a lot it's like
yeah there's no knowing these two
[ __ ] or at least like one of
them they they didn't start doing like
serial killer [ __ ] like early but they
clearly weren't
um
gonna be outstanding citizens I mean
they started doing like minor [ __ ] when
they were kids which like I said you
can't that's the thing you can't really
like predict because a lot of kids do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like they'll steal stuff
and everything and they turn out fine
like they straighten up and everything
like that these [ __ ] did not
sometimes two dirt bags can [ __ ] meet
each other and then they they're such a
bad influence on one another that
[ __ ] that might have been two years
later they're doing [ __ ] they never
would have done on their own that's the
situation now I don't think in this case
I know that that does happen sometimes
particularly when you see male females
hero Killers a lot of time like 95 of
the time like I don't think the woman
would have done [ __ ] on her own if she'd
never met this [ __ ] these two
since they're both dudes I kind of feel
like one of them for sure I think would
have just done the [ __ ] anyway I don't
think because he was already kind of
starting down that road the other one I
don't know he would have still been a
criminal because he started out doing
stuff young I don't know if he would
have graduated to the [ __ ] that they did
had they met each other and fed off but
there it's possible that he could have
because like I said he seemed like a
piece of [ __ ] like from a pretty early
age to our listeners I want to give you
some damn [ __ ] advice some good Sage
Eastern philosophy type advice this is
like some [ __ ] to [ __ ] the [ __ ]
zatoichi would tell you no it's not
zatoichi [ __ ] He's The Blind
Swordsman who's the other dude I was
gonna say yes
he's a fictional kid he's The Gambler
yeah this is more this is more like uh
[ __ ] old what's his name would tell
you do not [ __ ] start who Confucius
no
see now she's [ __ ] with me I'm trying
to get well I don't know
um
[ __ ] man [ __ ]
because of my head injuries sometimes
the [ __ ] dude's name will be on the
tip of my tongue I know everything about
him I can't remember a motherfucker's
name I have a hard time with names and
but I and I don't know and I think it's
just because if I'm afraid I forget if
I'm afraid that I'll forget the name
I'll forget it if I'm not even thinking
about it I'll remember it yeah I think
that kind of like yeah and they well I
do that too because sometimes I'm like
oh I know that [ __ ] I know that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then like I I
won't think of it but then like 10
minutes later it'll occur to me Musashi
talking about Musashi
famous Japanese [ __ ] swordsman was
not a samurai was a Yakuza all right uh
basically [ __ ] Outlaw all right he's
kind of like the Jesse James but he
wrote a good books and [ __ ] [ __ ] he
gave a lot of good advice and I could
stand by the advice because a lot of
[ __ ] he's talking about it's like yep
because they didn't have professional
militaries then they were
you had to learn it on your own but if
you serve in a professional military and
combat unit and [ __ ] you get involved
with bad [ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] that [ __ ] Musashi says
like exactly because it's a Timeless
values Musashi would say you better be
careful who you surround yourself with
okay because you could be a a decent
person but if you're around a bunch of
shitty people they'll bring the worst
out in you [ __ ] somebody can enrage
you and you kill them and then you end
up going to prison or some [ __ ] like
that okay so be careful about where you
go all right that fits in with these
girls hooking up with these P these
dudes the next thing you know he's a
serial killer and she kind of gets into
it or whatever
people have weaknesses and then other
people seek out these weaknesses and
[ __ ] can manipulate you into doing
weird [ __ ] sometimes I go that day I'll
biker bar if sometimes I'm like I
probably shouldn't be hanging in here
around these people you know because
sometimes you get mad you're going later
I'd like to beat that motherfucker's ass
see and I know how you get so it's
probably like not the best situation
yeah I kind of feel like one of these
days because I know how you do yeah one
of these days you're gonna be there and
you're going to call me from the bar and
be like uh I'm in jail because I just
like beat up a [ __ ] yeah I had
to beat this motherfucker's ass you know
what I mean or [ __ ] and then I'll be
like yeah I don't have the money to bail
you out so yeah
I think I might have to beat this
[ __ ] that's what I'm saying you
get but you get very I didn't say
anything though you get very much I
didn't say anything you know what I mean
that's why I'm worried about all of this
new like stuff that you're going yeah
I'm like that might like exacerbate well
I was on some [ __ ] this situation yeah
well yeah you were gonna beat up like
somebody that was like in our old
neighborhood that legit that just like
didn't stop quick enough or some [ __ ]
like that he was trying to [ __ ] it
wasn't really trying to get through a
space that I was already in it really
was like don't you not to [ __ ] drive
it really wasn't that big of a deal I
was [ __ ] going crazy though at that
time that's what I mean you want to
settle down right you need to settle
down because the next one on the list
people this is gonna be some weird [ __ ]
next time you see me [ __ ] I'm gonna
well no
I'm like I gotta clear this [ __ ] out I'm
gonna take some other [ __ ] that's
basically [ __ ]
synthetic [ __ ] bull testosterone oh
God yeah all right
next time you see me I might be a
[ __ ] Minotaur all right wait a
minute hold on I was gonna say a tour so
you're gonna be BTK BTK was a [ __ ]
Minotaur that's what he called himself
he thought he was a [ __ ] man oh
[ __ ] I'm in trouble
help me you guys help
he's gonna he's gonna go full BTK on the
ship I'm gonna cut through my [ __ ]
still don't you try nothing I'm Gonna
Knock You look at it
[ __ ] looking for the string that
Theseus laid
I was speaking of Bauhaus yeah that's a
nice call back from in the flat field in
case you guys don't know uh Zach says I
kept thinking you guys were talking
about the toy box killer yeah see the
toy box killer that was just one dude
that was that trucker yeah and I could
yeah I kind of feel like people we did a
show about him because Zach said didn't
you already do a show about him yes we
did
um I can't remember what what the [ __ ]
was his name Ray something uh or whips
and chains is what he called himself
yeah something like that this is two
guys yeah uh yeah this is two guys in
the 70s so we did do a show about the
toy box killer who was one guy but this
is two guys and it's toolbox Killers yes
I know it's confusing
um I was watching Bailey Syrian she did
a show about uh the toolbox Killers
earlier too which was she's adorable I
love her but um I guess that's why her
video had like 10 million views on it
because she's adorable but um just the
way she talked about [ __ ] it's adorable
but she did a show about this and that
came up like the toy box killer because
she didn't show about him as well but
yeah uh eraser says I'm not too familiar
with this case there seems to have been
quite a few serial killers in 70s
California yeah it was because we've
kind of talked about this before because
we've talked about a lot of serial
killer yeah it well it was a situation
where particularly like in the 60s and
70s everybody was going out to
California because you know hippies and
all that kind of stuff California right
that was kind of like the dream so you
go out there and you know most of the
people were fine and were okay but
they're because everybody was out there
you had like Predators following yeah it
was almost kind of like uh you know the
handful of predators were following like
this I was living in California at this
time as a little kid I [ __ ] grew up
in between Southern California and
Mississippi being traded opportunity mom
and my dad for over Mississippi in the
summer rest of the time [ __ ] Long
Beach and Carson California and uh
[ __ ] and it used to go up to the
[ __ ] Sequoia Redwood forest and
[ __ ] Yosemite California was [ __ ]
beautiful at this time all right it was
cool very cool but you had [ __ ] like
this running around
these two go Way Beyond Beyond [ __ ]
yeah I mean I think in the in the
description I called them sub-humans and
I don't use that term lightly yeah I
don't use that term lately good
um you know what I mean yeah chebette
says Lawrence bitticker looks nuts yeah
he does I get creeped out just looking
at him I'm guessing he was the
ringleader yeah these two I'm not really
sure
I don't know which one was the
ringleader they both seemed like really
[ __ ] up Lily Howell says you two look
extra amazing tonight thank you thank
you Wednesdays are wonderful because of
you no you you hugs and kisses stop it
stop it these are fun I mean I like
doing these getting bashful he's getting
bashful David Parker Ray that's that's
what the toy box killer is called I knew
it was Rey something I couldn't like
think of his name
uh yeah John Smith said I have a feeling
this footage will not be on true a true
crime documentary with us being
interviewed saying we just thought Tom
was joking yeah no that's what I'm
saying come on I said a Minotaur [ __ ] I
will knock your ass out part of this
[ __ ] look man you have to understand
something it's our jobs to be
entertainers okay I know exactly what
I'm talking about
I know I know the wrists
that's nowhere near as [ __ ] exciting
as I'm [ __ ] making this sound
this is kind of mundane [ __ ] but [ __ ]
you know this is about entertainment I
know that you guys are drinking and it's
it's hop day we are all
it's gonna be okay okay I'm a
professional okay don't worry about it
a professional what I don't know what
I'm a professor professional [ __ ]
yeah that's true oh my God can I make
you a card that says professional assets
hold on you don't have your little ears
out you're the earlier today you had
your little ears out there so cute you
put her little ears out yeah because
because the hair was bothering me so I
tucked it well see the thing about it if
I'm wearing stop oh you just stuck your
finger mayor
um if I'm wearing a different color wig
like the blue one or the purple one or
whatever I don't usually tuck the hair
behind my ears because then it's like uh
then you can see the hair underneath
sometimes or I'm at least I'm paranoid
about it I don't know if you can but
because my natural my hair is naturally
dyed black I feel like oh well I can
tuck my hair behind the ears it looks
like it won't look as weird because my
hair like my real hair is black under
there
so there's that Envy said law
enforcement seemed to be very naive and
not prepared for these types of
Senseless Predators back then yeah I
mean I kind of feel like that was the
situation and this situation in
particular I think one of the things
that made me really mad about this
before they even started their reign of
terror if you want to call it that
um these [ __ ] both of them
separately should absolutely have not
been out of jail because they had done
like so many [ __ ] crimes like
previously and they just kept getting
let out like they would do like little
[ __ ] sentences and then they would
get let out even for like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and then they would get let out again
and I know it was the 70s and everything
but [ __ ] you know it was the 60s and the
70s well you can't you can't just blame
law enforcement because what happens is
is that they're in a sea of criminals
and there's a lot of dudes that look
like this
it's just part it's just a system you
know
dudes get arrested they let they they
let them all go and like I'm giving them
[ __ ] life sentences that's the thing
it's like I know there's so many other
ones that look to the cops look just
like just like that like I get it I try
not to be too right because you know
hindsight is 20 20. so it's always kind
of like now we're looking at this now
from like 2020 like 2022 like after
these both of these [ __ ] they
know they were like this they would have
been really dead but it's just kind of
like you know it's easy to look back and
be like holy crap why did they let these
[ __ ] out well it's kind of like
the same thing that I said that both of
them should have been aborted like
nobody like you know the world would
have been like a marginally better place
how that happened but you know nobody
knew like to the extent I get it like
it's easy for us to look back yeah right
it's the 10 most of the time like I said
most of the time even kids that do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like steel and stuff or
like get in trouble with the law you
know only a small percentage of those go
on to become
serial killers are go on to become
murderers like some of them go on to
become lifelong criminals but it's just
kind of like non-violent [ __ ] so I do
kind of feel like even though we because
we know the outcome we know that these
people ended up like this and so it's
easy to like look back and be like Oh
red flag red flag red flag but it's like
back then like you said there was a lot
of people that were doing that [ __ ] and
they probably like grew out of it and
they were fine yeah that happened back
to ass do all kinds of weird [ __ ]
[ __ ] beat on a woman nearly kill and
rape a woman or whatever dude just gets
gets arrested [ __ ] goes to jail for
[ __ ] 15 years gets out at 35 and
[ __ ]
few years later he's married and got
kids and
and he lives the rest of his life and
never nothing ever [ __ ] but I mean
you never know you just you never know
which one is gonna like be okay and
which one is not you can only punish a
person for what they've done and what
you can prove that they've done
pre-crime and [ __ ] is a recipe for
disaster you'll lock up [ __ ] 30 of
the damn [ __ ] Earth's population yeah
okay because honestly even though yeah
it's a red flag like when people are
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] when they're kids
but even I don't know like what the
statistics of it are but it's a pretty
pretty small I mean it's a very very
tiny tiny tiny infinitesimal percentage
of the population is serial killers
anyway but of the people that had [ __ ]
up childhoods and did like really [ __ ]
up [ __ ] as they were as kids and like
did criminal [ __ ] when they were kids
like some of those kids yeah they went
to juvie or whatever but a lot of them
like got their [ __ ] together and they
had relatively normal lives you know
what I mean but you can never know like
which ones are are not gonna have that I
read a book written by a guy who uh
wrote the FBI's [ __ ] manual on this
he was an FBI agent and a psychologist
and psychiatrist and all that crap
he wrote the book on serial killers and
sex offenders
it was a long time ago I don't remember
the name of the guy or the actual book
but the it was an interesting book
I I agree with him a serial killers and
to be a serial killer
is a sexual orientation
it's who they are
it's very rare though very rare well
thankfully you're not going to change
them it's kind of like being a Serial
sex offender in terms they are serial
sex offenders they just kill rape
torture the [ __ ] victim not all
serious sex offenders do that some of
them are just into kids but they they
they don't ever hurt the kids they're
into the kids they love the kid uh other
ones will hurt the kid but the [ __ ]
serial killers are a [ __ ] sexual
orientation you're not going to change
it
yeah particular kinds of people and I
think in particular these two guys at
least one of them
um
I'm not sure I don't know if I'd go as
far as to say he was born bad but I
think that after a certain point I don't
think there would be anything that you
could do to rehabilitate him and
probably they should have just put him
down like a rabid dog it's somebody
who's way way into kind of like maybe
what we would call in the goth scene
BDSM but not consensual
and here's the deal it's not a ritual or
stylistic kind of BDSM it's the real
thing they want to [ __ ]
cut pieces off of people and make them
suffer and [ __ ] you know what I mean
it's about power and control and then
they murder that person yeah that's
what's going on this is a sexualized
thing for them
it's not normal man this is [ __ ] way
on the outside of [ __ ] like I said
thankfully like I said I know that you
kind of like to say like humans and
they're evil monkeys and everything like
that but I mean to be honest outside
here this is most people are
all right yeah
monkeys are all right most people are
all right a lot of evil monkeys that go
out and do [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and kill
people and [ __ ]
um it's understandable when you know the
situation that they're in they're in a
cartel they're trying to make money
their enemy car their enemy cartels that
they have to fight uh or people rat them
out and they have to [ __ ] kill the
people that are trying to [ __ ] rat
them out and that's a threat to their
organization it's always something
understandable
from the point of view of the offender
well what I'm saying too that you know
these guys it's about sexual
gratification
well yeah the thing about it is that
like a lot of murders and I know this is
like maybe a weird thing to say but like
a lot a lot of murders like you can kind
of understand why they were committed
like there was a reason like there's a
goal and it's a good right it's like I
wanted life insurance money or I you
know I got mad at my wife or my husband
for [ __ ] around on me or something
like that like I'm not condoning it I'm
just saying that it's understandable
right yeah but I think the reason that
people are fascinated by [ __ ]
like this like serial killers is just
because it's not understandable like you
know 99.99 of the population do not
understand just cruising around looking
for random ass people and getting off on
like most people don't
well thankfully like I said yeah you're
gonna snuff a person out for a few
minutes of [ __ ] sexual gratification
that's some [ __ ] heart that's some
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] man no that's not
acceptable
well obviously obviously that's
acceptable I mean at least with [ __ ]
organized crime
outfits there is something that it's
gold I mean they have a reason there's a
reason I'm not condoning it I'm not
saying it's a good reason I'm just
saying that it's an understandable
reason right and it's a lot of people in
the game the a lot of the person that
they're the person that they're killing
[ __ ] was somebody who worked with
them who's [ __ ] turned code and gonna
testify that that's a lot more
understandable uh
than [ __ ] just saying like man that
little that little girl's got a nice ass
I'm gonna kill her I mean that's
essentially what whoa It's like what the
[ __ ] is that isolated quickly yeah you
know yeah what are you talking about
John Smith says though Tom would have a
cool name the 13 o'clock killer right oh
man stop it
Chipette says Jenny where do you get
your wigs from I just get them from
Amazon yeah honestly uh this one and I
have like a bunch that are this length
it's hard to find ones of this length
because I have some that are really long
but I don't like to wear those out
because they're kind of a pain in the
ass because they're like really really
long pretty long underneath all that my
hair's about shoulder length at this
point so I just got them I think they're
like 20 bucks 25 bucks like from some
place on the internet that I got them so
I have this one I have a red one I have
a white one I have a blue one I don't
usually wear the white one all that much
I don't like it as much as I thought I
would but yeah Lee Lee Howell then says
Jenny where do you get your men from
[Laughter]
um yeah they're talking about Lily says
I have a crush on Tom but a bigger crush
on Jenny yeah yeah is that a guy or a
girl that's how that usually works I
don't know okay that's it could be a guy
that's a gender
it's gender neutral
Camp guy said yeah one of these killers
does look like David Cross he does yeah
I agree uh Danny Rowling said
Connecticut serial killer William Devin
Howell drove a van and killed hoes and
his fan and then buried them in a wooded
area upon his shopping centers make
shift graveyard for his victims yeah
this actually on I don't know if this is
because I kind of feel like there was
earlier cases that uh contributed to
this but you know how everybody like
makes the joke about like oh the the you
know serial killer van or the rape van
or whatever like the white windowless
band okay so that factored into this
case as well but I don't know if it was
the first time that that had happened
because I'm pretty sure that Predators
like people of this predilection if you
want to call it that I'm kind of uh you
know imagining they're like ooh they
they would see like the um the benefit
of having a van that didn't have Windows
on the side and that you could and like
these two [ __ ]
thought a great deal about this they
even named the van we'll get into that
but yeah but it wasn't white though it
was silver but still well I'm gonna uh
I'm gonna jump in and say most Vans are
white
yeah this one was silver though because
most Vans are commercial
and if you buy a used van chances are
it's gonna be white in the United States
they're
they're whole fleets of them companies
own fleets of those white Vans service
vans
they're good to have though a lot of
parts interchangeability Ford makes a
lot of them
they're they're good and they're they're
good vehicles the one needs easy to keep
running the one these [ __ ] [ __ ]
use was a GMC it was GMC I guess it was
yeah it's a little more rare most fleet
vehicles are Ford in the United States
and it was silver not way but like but I
get like right I mean that there is a
reason that that's a stereotype that
like the white windowless man yeah like
the the rape van or the kidnapping van
or [ __ ] like that yeah the reason why
they're mostly white and windowless
because there's so many of them you can
get one
used at auctions for [ __ ] very cheap
they come out of the fleet
and they come equipped with their own
camouflage
most your contractors are running that
van it's just the generic work van for
the United States
like I'm [ __ ] I was out there working
today saw [ __ ] four of them go by now
they have [ __ ] plastic graphics on
them you know the tape Graphics they
change them up but it's that same band
but I mean I'm gonna say that even
nowadays even in 2022 if I was walking
down the street and saw like a plain
white van with no windows on the side
that would absolutely be a red flag you
would unless you see those well you
wouldn't because you're not a woman yeah
but um but I would absolutely notice and
or I would also notice if it had like
really shitty cheap graphics on it like
they just drew on the side with a marker
or some [ __ ] like that
um you know if it's all like kitted out
like they paid some money like to get
some graphics then okay fine but if it's
just plain yeah or if they just have
like some cheap ass like magnet on the
side yeah I am absolutely staying far
away from that nowadays they mostly have
[ __ ] graphics on them yeah well
that's probably why because people like
me like I said you're a dude so it may
not might not occur to you but and after
you've heard this story you might
understand like why we're uh suspicious
but you know Zach says out of curiosity
which serial killer do you have the most
sympathy for
ooh
that's a heart uh Aileen warnose maybe
or
maybe Jeffrey Dahmer although man he did
some really messed up [ __ ]
but I don't know alien I have [ __ ]
sympathy for anything I don't either but
I'm just like I'm kind of like if you if
you put a gun to my head and ask me to
like that question
alien warnose I just feel like she kind
of got like a [ __ ] Raw Deal and maybe
I don't know if she necessarily would
have been a serial killer of
circumstances have been different
Jeffrey Dahmer did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but I kind of feel like had his
family upbringing been different than
maybe he would have turned out all right
but I'm not I don't know I'm not really
sure like I said there's no way of
knowing most of these [ __ ] I
have absolutely no sympathy for it all
because and the thing about it is that
you know I'm not saying that
you know if we can go back in time like
a lot of them did have [ __ ] up
childhoods like these two did have
[ __ ] up childhood well we've had like
people that we've talked about before
have had way more [ __ ] up childhoods
than these two had but their childhoods
were [ __ ] up and the thing about it
though is that a lot of people have
[ __ ] up childhoods and it's a tiny
tiny tiny tiny percentage become serial
killers so
after like up to a point I feel like
that's not really an excuse anymore
because a lot of people have [ __ ] up
childhoods and don't become serial
killers they grow up to become just
completely normal people like they
overcome it or whatever and so that's
why I think that it has to be
as I said a perfect storm of factors I
think it not only do you have to have a
[ __ ] up childhood I don't even know if
serial killers can be made necessarily
like unless the childhood was like
horrific then I could see it but I think
there has to be some kind of something
there already like to work with they
have to have some kind of genetic lack
of empathy or something like that and
then it's exacerbated by the upbringing
you know what I'm saying because
somebody that has like normal human
empathy and stuff like that they have a
[ __ ] up childhood and it's [ __ ] up
and they have like a lot of problems and
stuff like that but they turn out okay
because they still you know they still
understand like that other people are
people and can't be used for their own
purposes and [ __ ] so
I don't know it's kind of like a hard
thing to say so are we ready to kind of
get into this go ahead and go are we
ready to get into this case let's go all
right
um yeah chepette says we have the phrase
white van man in the UK it's used to
describe someone in white Vantage drives
like an [ __ ] yeah here like I kind of
feel like if you say oh the white van
you're talking about like the the rape
van or the abduction van because I kind
of feel like that's
and maybe that's unfair but because of
cases like this it's kind of like even
though this band was technically silver
and not white but it was a windowless
fan all the same and they used it for
exactly what you would imagine
um that people would use windowless fans
for it was the mobile rape fan that's
what I'm saying that's exactly what it
was yeah exactly yep the mobile rape
torture murder van and they're not the
only ones to have done that so like I
said it's not crazy to think that that
because some [ __ ] have ab and
they were very calculating in doing it
so let's get into this so these two
[ __ ] the toolbox killers
otherwise known as Lawrence bitticker
whose nickname this makes me want to
throw up his nickname in prison was
pliers and he was very proud of that and
you'll find out why later on that he was
proud of that nickname it is like yeah
it makes me want to like throw up and uh
Roy Norris known as the toolbox Killers
two American serial killers uh and
rapists let's not forget that and
torturers also uh they did kidnapping
rape torture and murder of at least five
teenage girls maybe more they're not
sure but five was what they were
convicted for in Southern California
over a five-month period in 1979.
I will note that I don't know if this is
the same FBI guy that you were talking
about but the very famous FBI special
agent John E Douglas who's uh stuff like
mind Hunter was based on
yeah he's that guy he very notably said
that Lawrence Whitaker yeah yeah all of
all of the serial killers that he
interviewed and it was a lot he said
that Lawrence bitticker was the worst
the most evil [ __ ] he had ever
talked to
so
when it's coming from somebody like that
that [ __ ] means something
so now we're just kind of like I know
that Tom is always like we have to like
say the ending before you get to the
thing now both these [ __ ] are
dead uh thankfully
but they only died recently though
Lawrence bitticker uh he got sentenced
to death right uh back in 1981. now but
he got sent to San Quentin and he just
died of natural causes in 2019 late 2019
December so he was still on death row
doing all the appeals we'll get into
that a little bit uh Roy Norris actually
he didn't get sentenced to death because
he did a whole plea bargain thing where
he's like oh I'll show you where some of
the bodies are and like all testify
against uh the other [ __ ]
bitticker and so he just got he actually
got a life sentence with possibility of
parole they never did give him parole
because of course they're not going to
uh but he also died of natural causes in
prison in February of 2020. so only a
couple years ago these [ __ ]
died neither one of them got tortured
sadly which probably they should have
been but you know at least they're dead
now at least they're dead
so as I mentioned they got called the
toolbox Killers obviously because a lot
of the tools that they the things that
they use like to torture their victims
were
tools that you'd have around the house
like pliers and [ __ ] like that and again
that's why Lawrence Whitaker was proud
of being called pliers it's like it's
super [ __ ] up
all right so
so these [ __ ] backgrounds
originally from Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
now he was born in 1940.
now as I alluded to earlier when he was
born like his parents
uh did not actually want children
and uh so his mother his biological
mother was very very upset when she
found out she was pregnant and like I
said it was the 40s she couldn't really
do the whole abortion thing so she gave
him up for adoption as soon as he was
born now he was adopted by Mr and Mrs
George bitticker uh pretty blue when he
was still an infant so I imagine he
didn't remember he obviously didn't
remember his uh biological parents now
his dad was like uh he works for
something like aircraft kind of thing uh
you know company so they so he moved
around a lot
they moved from Pennsylvania they moved
they lived in Florida for a while they
moved to Ohio and lived there for a
while and then finally they moved out to
California so Lawrence when he was in
school I don't think he was like
necessarily abused or anything like
physically abused or sexually abused or
anything like that but he did kind of
have a life sober he they didn't really
settle long enough for him to like
establish any friendships or anything
like that
now he actually dropped out of high
school in 1957 but even prior to that he
was one of those [ __ ] that
apparently they did an IQ test on him it
was 138 which is pretty high which is
pretty high uh so he was one of those
guys where he just thought school was
like a waste of time because he was too
smart for everybody and so he ended up
dropping out but prior to that he had
already started doing like uh do being
like a criminal essentially now most of
the stuff that he did early on earlier
on like with juvenile authorities and
everything that were fairly minor [ __ ]
it was usually like theft you know what
I mean like he was just stealing [ __ ]
now after he got after he dropped out of
high school though
he got arrested in Long Beach for uh
stealing a car and also a hit and run
and then when the cops try to like
arrest him like he took off evading
arrest so he got uh caught for that now
see so at that point he was still a
minor so he got sent to the California
Youth Authority and he stayed there
until he was 18 or 19 years old and then
they let him out
now
only a couple of days I think it was
only a couple of days like after he got
let out of the Youth Authority
he gets arrested again by FBI agents in
Louisiana
because apparently he had stolen a car
and like taken it across state lines
right so they caught him for that then
he got convicted on that charge in 1959
and then he got 18 months at a federal
Reformatory in Oklahoma
and at this point he started acting like
like I guess like the doctors or the you
know the authorities there were just
kind of like uh maybe there's something
wrong with this dude so they transferred
him actually to a medical center in
Missouri
um and had kind of like doctors observe
him but I guess they maybe thought that
oh it'll be all right like he's not
maybe he's not a danger because he only
served about two-thirds of a sentence
and then they let him out
now he got arrested again
in Los Angeles in 1960 for robbery and
he got convicted then in 1961 and he got
a sentence of basically like 1 to 15
years in a state prison
now at this point they did like a
psychiatric evaluation of him and the
psychiatrist at that point found
Lawrence bitticker to be uh manipulative
which like I said we're talking we're
going into like sociopath territory here
psychopath territory and uh the quote
was having considerable concealed
hostility
uh they did uh concede that he had
Superior intelligence
but their diagnosis was further that he
was quote borderline psychotic and
basically paranoid so probably not a
good time to be let out
they had another psychiatrist come in
and look at him like about a year later
who said that he had very poor impulse
control
now despite the psychiatrist coming in
and saying hey let's uh not let this
dude out he did actually get paroled in
1963 uh even though he had only served a
tiny tiny portion of the maximum
sentence right so even though two
psychiatrists came in and said let's
let's not let this dude run around loose
even back in the 60s they probably had a
big
um
prison population yeah maybe that's the
thing it couldn't hold everybody
they considered him to be lesser risk
than the guys that they had
so they let him go
yeah
American Military 100 as I said you
can't hold them forever
or you yeah let him go
I mean yeah and like I said hindsight's
20 20. I know that I'm like looking back
at this and being like man somebody
should have like you know killed them at
Birth or something like that but it's
you know you don't need it's Western
Civilization had this been China they
would have killed all those dudes
I mean the thing about it like I said 99
of the time even people that [ __ ] up as
kids or [ __ ] up and like do [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like most of them turn out like
okay you know what I mean a lot of them
turn out okay so you can't just like
kill people indiscriminately I get it
but
looking back on this dude I know but you
know what I'm saying yeah American
Military 100 said damn these toolbox
Killers bitticker Norris were a vile Duo
yes this episode is going to be Grim I
warned you I told you this is gonna be
bad this this one like really upset me
John Smith said the director of
Behavioral Science to the FBI used to
play the audio from these guys crimes
yeah we'll get into that uh to people to
change their minds on the death penalty
it usually worked yeah they recorded
stuff oh yeah okay
okay and uh yeah so
um and also I don't know if this is sure
or not but I think the FBI still I don't
know if they still do but I think for a
long time they used the audio from these
from this particular case
um to kind of train their uh their uh
their field agents or whatever just to
kind of not desensitize them necessarily
but say like this is the kind of
[ __ ] that you might be dealing
with kind of thing like nobody wants to
hear it because it's awful but you know
there's like yeah you might encounter
these kinds of kinds of people so you
should be probably like prepared
so yeah so this [ __ ] gets out in
1963.
two months after he was let out though
he got put in jail again for another
parole violation uh and suspicion of
robbery and then uh so he does that then
he gets back out then he gets another
parole violation and he goes back to
prison in October 1964.
now at this point like another
psychiatrist is interviewing him being
like what the [ __ ] bro like what is your
deal and apparently at this point
bitticker says that while stealing makes
me feel important
and also here was this to me like says
volumes right here that said a bunch of
my crimes happened quote under
circumstances that were not totally my
fault
yeah okay
well I gotta hear more do you see this
face this is yeah I'm this is my yeah
it's not well I did steal all that stuff
and kill people and do this but it
wasn't totally my fault I mean if you
look at it in a certain way I mean come
on now knock it off we've got a lot of
people in the Super Chat thank you very
much thank you very much people go ahead
and uh super chats are active if you
want to go ahead and send Jenny any kind
of tips for the work that she's done we
would very much appreciate it go ahead
Jenny that's that's your plug well thank
you very much that was like a commercial
yeah I'm just trying to hurry hurry it
up I won't pester anybody pester anybody
yeah okay
so at this point yes so this
psychiatrist also says
um this he's like a borderline psychotic
and probably should not be let out this
is the third psychiatrist if you're
counting that has said that
um but the authorities the other
authorities over the psychiatrists I
guess were like nah let him out it's
fine
so he gets out again now he gets another
parole violation in 1967. so he's going
like in and out of prison like I said
a month after he gets out from that he
gets uh caught again for theft and
leaving the scene of a hit and run so
that was that he got convicted on those
two and got another five-year sentence
but was paroled after serving less than
three years
so he got let out in 1970 spring of
1970.
then again he gets arrested for burglary
and another parole violation God damn
this is like stacking up right in March
of 1971 and got convicted on both of
those counts and got an additional
sentence of six months to 15 years which
seems like a little
broad you know what I mean six months
maybe could be six months or maybe could
be 15 years you don't know
so I mean the thing about it is that at
this point like you said
this is the 60s and the 70s
so I don't know they didn't really have
their [ __ ] together like I guess the
person's system and because this guy was
just in and out in and out like yeah
most of the crimes were minor but you
would think like after a certain amount
of time they'd be like and well it's not
just that because like I'm not really
that concerned about like just Petty
burglary and crap but if three size
separate psychiatrists have come to you
and said hey this dude's maybe like a
psycho and don't let them run around
maybe you should probably listen to that
if like three separate psychiatrists are
saying I'm just saying I'm just saying
just just approach it
so uh yeah so he got let out
in 1974.
and
so what happened then so he goes to do
another crime
so he goes to a grocery store is what he
does in 1974. and he decides he's gonna
steal a steak okay so he takes the steak
and he stuffs it down the front of his
pants which okay
so he does that and one of the employees
at the grocery store like sees him so
bitticker like leaves the store with the
steak down his pants and the employee
like follows him and he doesn't like
grab him or nothing like that as far as
I could determine the employee is
basically like hey did you forget to pay
for that that's I think that's all he
said
at which point bitticker turns around
like this in the parking lot of the
grocery store it turns around and stabs
him in the chest missing his heart by
like an inch the dude did survive
thankfully thank you Jeffy art
listening to you guys is like a soothing
bubble bath after a long ass day thank
you is it really knock it the [ __ ] off
I find that hard well maybe it is maybe
it is yeah maybe it is I don't know I
don't get it but okay but yeah so
so basically so he stabbed somebody and
could have killed them easily I mean he
was obviously trying to kill him because
he stabbed him right in the chest and
like I said missed the Heart by an inch
the person survived thankfully but the
fact that he would do that over a steak
I mean that obviously shows
um yeah the dude's got some problems so
he stabs the guy now a couple of other
now he actually got caught this time
because a couple of other employees at
the grocery store came out and like
restrained him until the police got
there and like I said the the employee
that had confronted him like survived so
that was good but like I said it could
have it could have gone another way
now at this point
um they bring in another psychiatrist
which I believe is the fourth one now
for Christ's sake uh why is there nobody
listening to us they're probably saying
so before he goes on trial for this
particular thing because this is like
attempted murder right I mean pretty
much
so he says okay I don't think that
borderline psychosis which was the
previous uh you know diagnosis he's like
I don't think that's entirely accurate
he said I think that bitticker is what
he called a classic sociopath have to
agree with that
um by which he meant that bitticker and
this is a quote was incapable of
learning to play by the rules he would
never learn by experience and he would
just keep butting his head against the
barriers of acceptable behavior so
basically what he was saying was this
[ __ ] is hopeless so please do
not let him out in the streets like
among normal people because he's never
going to be able to play well with
others so you know
and uh this psychiatrist Dr Markman also
said
um he's not going to stop he's going to
keep doing this and he's going to move
on to more serious crimes he called him
quote unquote highly dangerous
um that he had no impulse control and he
said he basically said this in his thing
he will kill without hesitation or
remorse that's what he said and this is
before he had killed anybody that they
know of so the psychiatrist that kind of
pegged him
um now it should be noted too that
according to somebody that did some time
with bitticker uh around this time
period he actually did say that
bitticker had bragged to him that he
wanted to be quote unquote bigger than
Manson
which you know good it's good to have
goals but uh please don't have that one
so uh at this point like some other
prison psychiatrists came forward and
they kind of like went along with Dr
Markman
so they did a jailhouse evaluation in
1977 and they said yeah it's very very
likely that this [ __ ] will
probably commit more crimes when he's
released
um and then they had another
psychiatrist come in in 1978 that said
the same thing and he called him quote a
sophisticated psychopath
um and said probably you shouldn't let
him out on parole
so how many psychiatrists is this now
saying please don't let this man out a
lot
um but nobody listened uh they let him
out again in late 1978.
the thing about it though was that when
he was in prison this time
he met his little buddy
that would go on to cause all of this
[ __ ] misery he met Roy Norris when he
was at this [ __ ] place and these two
would go on to do like all kind of
horrible things so let's talk about Roy
neuer's Roy Norris for a second
so this [ __ ] uh was born in
Colorado in 1948 so he was about I think
he was eight years younger than uh then
bitticker was
now again he had kind of a troubled
upbringing he was actually like his
parents uh gave Burton like out of
wedlock which is a big deal back in 1948
so his parents had kind of like were
like well we better get married or
everybody's gonna look at us funny so
they got married so they wouldn't have
like the whole illegitimate baby kind of
crap now his dad uh worked at a
scrapyard or something his mom was a
housewife and was also addicted to drugs
I don't know what kind of drugs uh but
you know now uh I guess the thing about
it was that he lived with his parents a
lot of the time
but he kind of got shuttled off uh now
and again like when his mom just
couldn't deal with his [ __ ] and she
would like send him to foster homes and
stuff uh so I don't really know so he
was kind of like bounced around a lot
and he basically says when his
biological parents when he was living
with them that you know he kind of went
through a lot of neglect they would tell
him all the time but it's like we didn't
really want you and all this other kind
of crap and they would send him to live
with other Foster families and they
wouldn't give him any food or any
clothes and [ __ ] like that also there
was kind of a thing um and I don't know
if this is true or not but he said later
on that he had been fostered out to a
Hispanic family and was sexually abused
by one of them or something like that
and that fueled his racism I guess like
against Hispanic people like for the
rest of his life I don't really know
just because one allegedly did something
to him I don't know I don't get it but
yeah so he said that he got like abused
by different families maybe it's true I
don't really know but it does seem like
his biological parents uh hadn't really
wanted him and uh let him know about it
now one of the first things that comes
to light about his situation and the
thing about it is that even though I
kind of feel like bitticker like
Lawrence bitticker is perceived as the
ringleader of these two Norris was
actually the one that had the history of
sexual crimes bitticker had a long rap
sheet but most of his [ __ ] was like
theft auto theft [ __ ] dude it's okay
was like auto theft crap like that was
like more minor [ __ ] like robbery
um whereas Norris seemed to start out
younger as like a specifically like
sexual criminal you know what I'm saying
like his earliest crimes were like
sexual in nature whereas bittickers
weren't so much so I don't know like I
said it's an interesting Dynamic so
that's what I'm saying about even if
these two [ __ ] hadn't met each
other they wouldn't have they wouldn't
have been upstanding citizens either one
of them I mean I'm pretty sure Norris
probably would have been a serial killer
anyway like even if he hadn't met
bitticker bitticker Maybe
maybe he would have been a serial killer
I I it wouldn't surprise me even though
he just started out with robbery but
the fact that they met each other and
were like oh we have common interests
which is [ __ ] up but yeah I think that
but I think they probably would have
been
probably would have been Killers uh in
their own regard I don't necessarily
think it was a thing having to do with
oh one likes burned the other one I
think they were both like [ __ ] and
they just like hung out together
so uh so the first thing that happened
with Norris
he was uh living with his biological
parents and he was uh 16 years old 16 17
years old
and he actually went over to
um a female relatives I think it was his
aunt and I think she was like 20 years
old so she was like four years older
than him
and he started saying like all kind of
like creepy sexual [ __ ] to her at which
point she you know understandably was
like get the [ __ ] out of my house you
creepy little teenager
um and she actually told Roy's dad about
it
and then Roy's dad was like man I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of that little
[ __ ] which I don't condone but
I'm just saying
um so after that after after Norris's
dad like yelled at him he stole his
dad's car and drove into the Rocky
Mountains and then tried to commit
suicide by injecting air into an artery
in his arm
uh it didn't work no sadly but um which
again what could have been prevented but
yeah it didn't work but he did try to do
that like I said I'm not saying that
it's like oh that's cool that it's like
that he had a shitty childhood I'm just
saying that
in hindsight in retrospect it would have
been better had he succeeded but you
know he did
now he later got picked up as a runaway
and was returned to his parents now when
he was returned to his parents uh you
know basically his parents were like
well we never wanted you anyway and he
had a sister too and uh they also told
the sister that you guys were unwanted
children and um you know as soon as
you're 18 and you get the [ __ ] out of
our house we're gonna get divorced
because we only stayed married because
of you [ __ ] yeah so you know
that's a and like I said that's not cool
that's not cool and I'm and you know and
I'm not saying that like everybody that
endures a childhood like that like you
have my sympathies I don't have any
sympathy for these [ __ ] because
I know what they did later you know what
I'm saying that's all I'm saying
now uh so Norris actually lived in his
hometown in Colorado I think it was
called Greeley Colorado until he was 17
years old and he also dropped out of
high school and joined the Navy now he
got stationed in San Diego but uh he
actually did get sent to Vietnam for
four months he didn't see any combat uh
but while he was there he got real into
drugs marijuana is the one they usually
bring up I've also seen some sources say
that he really got into heroin I don't
know if that's true or not um smoking
weed that just almost doesn't even seem
like all that weird to me so I don't
really know why people bring it up but
whatever
um so yeah
so he gets back to Southern California
in late 1969.
and he actually
uh in San Diego
he forced his way into a woman's car and
tried to rape her
okay so he got picked up for that but he
didn't do that much time for it like he
was out like a couple months later
a couple months after that two or three
months after that he gets arrested again
now he's free on bail
um you know because he was on bail like
for attacking that woman in the car
and he goes up to a random woman's house
like in San Diego knocks on her door and
says hey like let me I don't know what
his excuse was but he was trying to get
it like get her to let him in and uh you
know she obviously was like um no and so
then he tried to break into her house
like I think he just wanted to oh I
gotta use your phone and she was like
yeah hell no [ __ ] that and so then he
tries to like break in through her
window and then like ran around to the
back of the kitchen tried to break in
back there
so he actually did break the window and
got into the house but she like called
the cops and the cops got there before
he could do anything to her thankfully
so like I said this dude was doing like
sexual predator [ __ ] from a very early
age you know
now uh so the Navy found out about these
uh things that he was doing and they
kicked him out now he got an
administrative discharge for uh
psychological problems and got diagnosed
as having what they called back then a
severe schizoid personality
now while he was still like waiting to
be uh you know indicted or not indicted
but kind of like put on trial for the
other like assault cases and [ __ ] like
that he attacked another woman in May of
1970 and this was a woman that was a she
was a student at the San Diego State
College and he had actually been kind of
like stalking her and like following her
around for like sometime he grabbed her
from behind hit her in the back of the
head with a stone and then like kept
slamming her head on the [ __ ]
sidewalk like she lived but Jesus Christ
so he just like pulled up and I don't
even know if it was nighttime or was the
middle of the day or what but he just
like started doing this and he was like
still what is he at this point 17 18 19
years old Jesus Christ yeah that's
attempted murderer in Most states yeah
so he at that point like he got caught
for that and he put got put in a state
hospital they called him a quote unquote
mentally disordered sex offender yeah no
[ __ ]
he was there for five years and then he
got released on probation because
apparently uh whoever that it was there
that um that you know analyzed him said
oh he's been here for five years he's no
further danger to others yeah little
little did they [ __ ] know little did
they [ __ ] know like I said this is a
sexual orientation I don't think you can
change these guys
I don't think they get better I think
they get worse yeah this guy in
particular
um I kind of feel like really the only
and what we see a lot with serial
killers and we saw this with BTK and all
this other kind of stuff they still have
that proclivity it's just that after a
time I kind of feel like they get too
old or the infirm they can't like move
around like the way they used to find
and [ __ ] like that so yeah but I mean
you saw it with BTK and stuff like that
where he still wanted to do it right he
just couldn't he just couldn't really do
it anymore because he was older and blah
blah blah so I don't know
I don't think like dudes of this I don't
want to say caliber because that sounds
like a good thing but it's ilk this type
of this type I don't really think that
they can be fixed and it's a pretty
small percentage of people that are just
beyond all yeah these people and these
two particularly I think these two
[ __ ] were just beyond help
I don't think there's anything that you
could have done at any point
to prevent yeah you could have I mean
maybe if it killed him well yeah well
yeah obviously but I'm just saying I
these two guys no these two guys I don't
know if you'd got them early liquids
they'd had a normal childhood maybe they
would have turned out okay I mean
there's no way of knowing but I mean
once they got into their teenage years I
think they were probably past it I think
they were it was too far gone not normal
heterosexual heterosexual activity
just didn't
I mean yeah
this dude yeah and the thing about it
like neither one of them really seemed
to particularly care about being caught
because even though bitticker like I
said most of his early crimes were minor
[ __ ] like robberies and stuff but I mean
they let him out after a couple months
and then he just go do it again and he
didn't really seem to give a [ __ ] about
this like oh well doing another couple
months like he didn't really seem to
care about being caught and the same
thing applied with sexual crimes to to
this other [ __ ] to Norris
because I mean like I said he would just
like run up to people and like sir beat
their head against the sidewalk and like
[ __ ] and he got caught and sent to
hospitals and [ __ ] and he's just like
whatevs whatever they didn't care
whatever it is it isn't some kind of a a
modern thing it was been around a long
time I mean H.H Holmes was a guy kind of
like this yeah it seems to go back a
long long way yeah there's always been
something like this always yeah just
there wasn't as many of them when the
population was lower before the modern
era and you didn't hear about it as much
because the media wasn't like worldwide
yeah and you can get away with it I mean
that too you had weirdos in the [ __ ]
1500s that were running around raping
and killing women and trying to eat them
and stuff and then they would say well
I'm an air I'm a werewolf that's why I
did it yeah you know yeah I don't think
this is this is absolutely not a new
phenomenon it's just like freakiness
that [ __ ] happens as some kind of
genetic problem and
you know their uh their mutants of some
sort yeah like by the scientific uh you
know definition of that word what a
mutant is yeah that's what I'm saying I
kind of feel like there are it's and
it's probably a very small percentage
because I think even people that are
born with let's call them like
sociopathic proclivities if they're
raised in like a normal household and
have like normal experiences and
everything like that I think most of the
time most of them will not obviously
become serial killers they might be
[ __ ] but you know some of them
actually do pretty well like in business
and stuff like that
um because those are kind of the you
know personality attributes that do well
in certain situations so it's very it's
a very small percentage I think that it
has to be usually
um a combination it has to be a
combination if you already are
genetically pre-wired for that type of
thing and then you have kind of like a
really shitty upbringer you have some
bad [ __ ] that happens to you like in
your formative years that put you on
that path that you can't really stray
from yeah and you can't like uh make a
connection between what these guys are
doing which is base they're basically
doing this for sexual gratification at
their own risk you know what I mean like
they're doing this [ __ ]
for a few hours or moments or days of
[ __ ] pleasure
even though they're gonna die this is a
Kamikaze mission that they're on they
know they'll eventually be caught
you can't equate them to say a dude from
the 1400s or 1500s you know say like a
like a Vlad tepesh or Prince Vlad the
Impaler you know big difference well
it's all context yeah Prince vlad's
doing a lot worse [ __ ] on a [ __ ]
bigger [ __ ] scale impaling [ __ ]
dudes right but he's doing this for for
his Nation his and his people you know
this is [ __ ] he's doing it to [ __ ]
spread fear and Terror against a [ __ ]
Turkish enemy you know which
he went down it's like [ __ ] well a
lot a lot of I guess modern people don't
really know who Prince Vlad is but
that's what Dracula was based on
he was a bad mother everybody knows that
come on but this is gold directed
violence yeah he's doing this [ __ ] but
he's trying that's what we were saying
before it's like you know no one's very
different no one is advocating or you
know condoning like what like right
sticking stuff up people's butts and
like leaving people because that's
[ __ ] up I don't care how much you hate
somebody but it works though the Turks
came in this oh yeah but beat a dude
who's who could do this right that's
what I'm saying yeah but that was like I
said it's not we're not condoning it I'm
just saying that it's understandable in
the context it's about a goal right the
reason people are fascinated by serial
killers is because you don't you can't
understand it because people can't
understand it the goal is very
compassionated because most people don't
have
even you know even in your Darkness so
they can bust a nut they're doing this
essentially it was that's [ __ ] very
Petty yeah you're gonna kill another
person over that what are you talking
about yeah at least a guy like Prince
Vlad he's doing it for [ __ ] to
pretend protect his homeland to get in
to chase out enemies to be fierce you
know it's psychological warfare you know
you can even say [ __ ] mustache man
with a bent cross at least he thought
he was doing it for a for a person even
though he was a nut I mean he thought
well just him it was all the other ones
well well yeah it was all that doesn't
imply that the other ones weren't nuts
too it was it was war racial Warfare you
know what I mean they're trying to
[ __ ] achieve a goal that they that
they want yeah so at least that's kind
of more understandable than this dude
well I want to bust a nut so I'm gonna
kill your 15 year old daughter with a
pair of pliers I'm gonna pull her
nipples off you know it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here man what
kind of crazy stupid [ __ ] is that I mean
what kind of goal is that
yeah well you know that's what I'm
saying yeah
[ __ ] Ed V said I bet there were guys
in jail for possession of marijuana that
they kept inside while they let this
monster out they probably did that's I
think that's what makes me mad about it
because and like I said it's not like
when people talk about you know the
system or the authorities and stuff like
that you have to think it's not just one
faceless thing it's just a bunch of
flawed ass people and it's like this
person it's like oh I dropped this thing
behind my desk and they don't know what
they're doing in the next office and
[ __ ] like that so [ __ ] happens I get it
but I'm sure that probably did happen
and I think that's one of the things
that's like frustrating John says that
they're outliers of the the neurology
yeah yeah that's what I'm thinking yeah
they are that's what I think they are
and like I said I definitely do think
that you have to have some kind I don't
know I don't know if I want to say this
outright but
it might be I kind of feel like it's
super super vanishingly rare for a
serial killer to be made I'm not saying
that it can't happen
um but I think you would have to endure
like really really horrible uh [ __ ] like
in your childhood I think you already
have to be a little bit predisposed to
that kind of personality thing and then
it's all like ties up together but like
I said I don't like to make real like
General statements like that because
there's always going to be outliers
there's billions of people in the world
and there's always going to be like a
small percentage that you know yeah they
had a completely normal childhood and
loving parents and everything like that
and still ended up like that it's like
you know what I mean or vice versa
so yeah so they let this [ __ ]
out Roy Roy Norris uh saying he's no
further danger to others well like I
said little did they know three months
later it wasn't even it was literally
three months later
uh he's in Redondo Beach cruising the
streets on his motorcycle
and he sees this 27 year old woman who
she had been out to dinner with a
boyfriend they'd had a fight and she was
like [ __ ] you and she like walked home
by herself
and so Roy stops and says hey I'll give
you a ride on my motorcycle and again
she says [ __ ] no uh you know as as you
would because like who the [ __ ] are you
I don't know you uh so yeah she turned
him down
so at this point uh Roy jumps off the
motorcycle and attacks her like he
basically took her own scarf wrapped it
around her neck and started strangling
her and then dragged her into the bushes
and raped her
so
yeah
even if you like tell them no they're
still gonna like you there's because she
was basically like yeah no thanks I
don't need a [ __ ] ride and then he
just [ __ ] grabbed her and dragged her
in the bushes
now she did survive thankfully
but she um she didn't get a real good
look at him and uh you know and she
hadn't got a real good look of I mean
she knew what the motorcycle looked like
and [ __ ] like that but she didn't get a
real good look at him so she did report
it to the cops but you know they
couldn't she couldn't give them like a
super good description so they were just
kind of like they couldn't catch him but
a month after that she was like hanging
out doing whatever she was doing and she
saw the same motorcycle again and she
recognized it so this time she was like
ooh that [ __ ] so she uh wrote
down the license plate number on the
motorcycle
now uh so he did get caught this time so
he got caught for the raid
so he actually got sent to uh the
California men's colony
and that's kind of so that's where he
ended up meeting Lawrence bitticker
though now I don't know like I'm not a
connoisseur of Prisons or anything like
that but from what I've heard the
California men's colony in this time
period was that you know it's not a
cakewalk it's a [ __ ] prison but
compared to some other places you could
be sent to it probably wasn't quite so
bad now so Roy Norris who's in there for
[ __ ] rape like dragging a woman into
the bushes and raping her
um he meets Lawrence bitticker and it's
a match made in Hell gonna say
so what okay so Norris's story is that
well
um a couple of times I don't really know
the details of all this because I don't
think he ever said what they were but he
said while he was at this prison
like I guess he got attacked by the
other inmates like in like just yeah I
guess like somebody like would want to
beat his ass or something like that and
that bitticker had jumped in and saved
him a couple times so he felt like oh he
owed him like a debt or some [ __ ] like
that
um also there was a thing where like one
of them like taught the other one like
in the Arts and Crafts class like to
make jewelry or something so they
started hanging out so they started like
becoming friends these two [ __ ]
and as they started talking they're kind
of like this is so [ __ ] up because
it's just kind of like in normal life
you you know you would meet somebody
somewhere and be like hey you like
horror movies hey you like
cooking hey you like this that and the
other you know you like pina coladas and
getting caught in the rain or whatever
and it's like hey I like that stuff too
okay so the same thing happened here but
in the most [ __ ] up way possible
because when they started hanging out
and talking to one another they started
discovering that they had similar uh
[ __ ] up sexual fantasies about hey we
can only get off by dominating and
raping and torturing women
weird so they start like hanging out
with each other you know now uh beta
thinking right there well yeah I mean
so Roy is kind of like I feel like he's
kind of the dude that like sort of brags
about [ __ ] so he's like bragging about
yeah I like I raped because he did
that's why he was in prison for rape and
he had like attempted it like several
times but he actually like went through
that one time and he got arrested so
he's in there for rape and then
bitticker says to him you know like if I
ever raped him because he hadn't raped
anybody that we know of like by this
point like bitter hadn't but he's like
oh well if I ever did that I would just
kill her afterwards so that there
wouldn't be a witness and so Roy is
probably like oh duh why didn't I think
of that it was just kind of it was that
kind of funny I don't know if that's
what happened but that's what it seems
like
um and then they get together God this
is this makes me so mad this whole case
is just making me so bad don't get mad
because it's happened a long time ago
with [ __ ] Deuces from a long time ago
and I know but it's but they're dead now
I mean they're dead now but you know
so the two of them are like oh you know
what would be fun you know be fun is if
we play this game
we're gonna pick one victim from each
year of the teenage years so a 13 year
old a 14 year old a 15 year old a 16
year old all of those like from 13 to
19. yeah and we're gonna pick one and
we're gonna like rape and murder them
and see oh and also they wanted to see
how long they could keep them like alive
and how long they could make them suffer
like before they killed them
so
this was goal directed violence too but
the goal is like stupid that was the
goal
that was their game we're gonna have
like one victim from each teenage year
and we're gonna keep her alive as long
as possible and see it's not a normal
goal though well obviously yeah I mean
that shouldn't really need to be said
right but yeah
true gold directed violence is Julius
Caesar trying to [ __ ] take you know I
mean get
take control of the [ __ ] Roman
Republic so he could become you know
what I mean the first uh dictator of
[ __ ] Rome you know because they're
[ __ ] up they were [ __ ] up we need we
still need to finish season two I know
we still haven't yeah but yeah like I
said I don't like I said I'll condone it
but I understand
murdering people for money or power or
because you're mad or something like
that like I get it I don't condone it I
wouldn't do it to someone who's in the
way right but but I get it like I
understand like [ __ ] like this what the
[ __ ] like they are just and I told you
before like Sophie
one of our uh one of our friends and
fans of the show uh she actually gave me
the book about BTK which was all about
like confessions of Assyrian it was all
like his writings like letters that he
had sent to the writer of the book and
his mindset I'm reading his [ __ ] and I'm
just like this dude is like a [ __ ]
alien like the stuff that he thought was
just like alien to me you thought it was
a mentor
yeah like I'm the Minotaur
that's the thing I'm the Minotaur no not
yet
so I'm like in a way I was like reading
it being like what the [ __ ] but then I
was like well I guess that makes you
feel better because maybe I'm like
normal yeah because obviously I'm like
what the [ __ ] man like what are you even
talking about like it no I had never
thought anything like that like this
dude had thought or like this dude's
like thought processes were like
completely alien to me which like I said
that's good that means that I'm a normal
person but yeah you know what I mean
it's so this kind of [ __ ] it's just like
what how does that occur to you like
look I'm a horror writer I like horror
movies I've seen some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I've imagined some [ __ ] up [ __ ] I'm I
imagine [ __ ] up [ __ ] but it's like
actually wanting to do it in real life
and like getting off on doing it it's
like that I don't understand that at all
I don't look the motive is always sexual
I know I don't get it so I'm saying it's
a sexual orientation it's it's [ __ ]
not normal whatever you know whatever it
is yeah obviously well and thankfully
because otherwise these [ __ ] would be
running around everywhere they're just
they're they're a modified
they're a modified rapist serial rapists
is what they are well that's what these
[ __ ] were like I said Nora started
out as a rapist
um but and bitticker started out more as
like a like a robbery guy yeah but then
when they met up with each other uh you
know then they started oh let's do the
whole rape thing but also we'll murder
them so they don't like finger well rape
and robbery are similar
when you think about it you're taking
things that don't belong to you
you know you see a woman she doesn't
belong to you you're gonna take it I
mean she doesn't belong to anybody
you're robbering
you're robbering sex
okay it's the same thing well no they
don't see other people as people in the
way you're thinking of it they're
thinking of people yeah I know items you
know what I mean well that's kind of the
depth that's one of the definitions of a
sociopath is you just see other people
as essentially NPCs you see them as a
means to an end that's just a means
that's you don't think of them as
another human with the same right they
kind of see themselves as that too
though also well but the thing is is
that they love their they love
themselves
yeah even though they don't really have
a sense of self in the way that I think
a healthy person has
I think that's what I think that's what
got me about the BTK book is because so
much of that book was like his thoughts
because he was like writing down like at
length and the weird thing to me was
that he really did well I wouldn't go
this far but he did actually seem to
love and I'm using like bunny rabbit
ears here uh you know air quotes love
his wife and daughter and wouldn't want
anything done to them but he didn't see
anybody else
um the same way that he said like he
didn't really seem to be like well
you know the other people that you
killed like that was someone else's wife
someone else's daughter somebody else's
husband somebody else's son or whatever
so he didn't really seem able to grasp
that concept and the thing about it is
that I think he is so [ __ ] up
I don't even think he he said oh he
loved his wife and daughter but I think
that it was the kind of a thing I don't
think it was love in the sense that a
normal person would no it was a sense
that well these are my possessions and I
don't want anything done but like don't
get your grubby mids on my possessions
but I don't give a [ __ ] about anybody
else right right that's probably he just
thought of other people as like just
stuff like other people's stuff right
this is my stuff you don't [ __ ] with my
stuff even though they're people
obviously but that was the impression
that I got yeah and and if you were to
actually probably kind of like if you
were able to like teleport yourself in
into his mind to see how he feels about
himself you'd find out that he feels
about himself in a very different way
than you feel about yourself
he probably doesn't have a sense of self
I think exactly yeah I think that's what
weirded me out the most about a robot
what he was saying yeah like some of the
I that's what I I think that's maybe
what I meant when I said that a lot of
times yeah like seemed alien to me
because I'm like are you even a person
no like yeah I mean no they're not
people in the way that you no more like
a lizard they don't think the same way
they're not in that reality John Gore
said some people really bad people are
really good at compartmentalizing and
honestly like BTK was kind of the
champion of that he just seemed like he
even like he seemed a little bit aware
of it where he would he didn't call it
compartmentalizing he called it um he
had a word for it X Factor no that
wasn't what it X Factor was something
else that was his section he called it
what the [ __ ] did he call it he had a
term for it but it meant
compartmentalizing yeah it was just he
would put things in different boxes you
know what I mean
so Alex Rivera said um that's just
because he saw his wife and daughter's
extensions of himself yeah I think
that's how he saw it like like I said he
saw it as like this is my stuff like
nobody [ __ ] with my stuff right but I
don't think he saw them as people
like the same way that not in the scene
that you and I would see someone else as
like a person right you know what I mean
which most people have that right and
but he did not have that look
I spent my whole adult life and yeah and
actually during the upbringing of myself
as
coming up in a military academy and
ended up in some of the best infantry
units the U.S army had
I always saw myself as a as a fighter
and a professional fighter kind of like
the same way a [ __ ] Ultimate Fighter
or UFC or MMA would see themselves
it's not this it's it's it's not the
same as these guys at all okay
when you fight enemy soldiers it's a lot
harder because you know there are people
just like you
they're just like you
when you're in Afghanistan or Iraq
fighting those guys they are patriotic
guys fighting for their country and
their way of being well and they have
families like you have it's like they
love their wife and kids and you know
and husbands and daughters and [ __ ] like
that just like you do and as infantry
you [ __ ] psych yourself up you kind
of dehumanize the enemy that helps
protect you
from all this but you know what it is
you know what you're doing okay it's
it's professional soldiery
they're kind of in the same mindset too
you know it's a game these guys don't
have any of that for them
it's not a game it's reality they're
[ __ ] psychos they don't have to be
well they don't have to [ __ ] protect
themselves yeah the thing about it is
that you know people in the military
stuff like that that have to go out and
like kill the enemy or whatever right
they honestly like a lot of those people
can't handle it yeah a lot of guys like
women as a regular person yeah it wasn't
a person yeah and that's why they go
through those dehumanizing and in a way
like that's [ __ ] up but in a way
that's encouraging because it's like
well the reason I mean the the thing
that you have to do that the reason you
have to do that is because most people
are not okay with it yeah naturally most
people are like hey that's another
[ __ ] just like me that also has
a family that loves them and also has so
you can see yourself in that even if
they look different or whatever so most
people do have that naturally and even
like other animals have that too so it's
not just a human thing so much easier to
kill a bad person yeah so there is a
thing so that's why like when you get
into stuff where people you know where
they want you to like kill other people
that's the first thing they do is
dehumanize them like kind of call them
like other names like that you know like
sub-human type of stuff yeah well you
know they're just yeah
their enemy you know yeah that's that
that's the idea you're trying to make
them seem monstrous or so so it's not so
hard right to kill them right but these
[ __ ] don't seem to have that
problem no they're trying to get
intimate with because they don't have
the natural human proclivity I don't
understand it at all of like because
most people honestly like I said humans
are greater or lesser degrees obviously
empathy it's on a spectrum but most
human beings have some
you know capacity for that it's a very
human like I said animals have a two
primates have it so it's not just us so
the fact that these [ __ ] can
just come out and just be like not they
give zero [ __ ] yeah they do not care
they just see everybody else as a thing
yeah they don't see you as a person and
like you said I think to an extension I
think they don't even see themselves as
a person I don't think they do I don't
think they do either I don't think they
understand what that means well I don't
think they understand what I mean I was
trying to tell you earlier on I've been
drinking
as somebody who has experience in this I
don't want to [ __ ] say everything
about my background it's never really
been that much but if somebody has
experience with all this
they must not see themselves as human to
be able to do what they're doing to
these girls yeah I don't think they do I
don't think they do
I couldn't do it I couldn't do that
you know what I mean I would have a hard
time doing the [ __ ] that they did to
like a person that I hated yeah yeah I
have most people would I have to be
enraged to do my thing you have to be a
bad person it has to be Vengeance it has
to be something that's [ __ ]
understandable and here's the thing
y'all are the same way whether you admit
it or not
somebody were to hurt Pookie or hurt
Jenny or to [ __ ] over my [ __ ] your
[ __ ] ass is grass I don't care what
the law says I'm gonna [ __ ] die I'm
gonna die
in a kamikaze type situation protecting
the things that I care about
I don't care I'm ready to die
just like
yeah right yeah I'm all right okay
just like Musashi said you do not have
the right to pick up the sword
and kill other people until you have
accepted that you yourself will die by
the sword who are you to kill someone
else all right and then cry like a [ __ ]
when it's your turn to die by that same
sword if you're in that game you're
gonna die
okay you better [ __ ] accept reality
all right that's what I'm saying uh if
you get into that [ __ ] game of
Warfare
or professional soldiering you're gonna
die you just have to [ __ ] accept that
you may die later than others you might
die before but you're still going to die
you do not have the right to kill other
people without being killed yourself
die live by the sword die by the sword
that's the Western and [ __ ] Musashi
knew that way back in the day
okay
these [ __ ] are a totally
different thing this is a damn
an aberration okay is that that's not
the way it's not the way human beings
are supposed to be
yeah that's what I'm saying that's why I
think most of these [ __ ] yeah
99 of these [ __ ] I think
there's something like the matter with
them like genetically are they or
they're missing something these are
these are lizards no no no they're not
even lizards yeah don't offend lizards
yeah I'm not gonna yeah
lizards they're monsters lizards they're
kind of [ __ ] but I saw one lizard
big lizard eat a little lizard of the
same species
but I don't know you know that that was
the same thing he's just like hey food
look at the food yeah
I had a pet lizard for a while yeah he
was kind of a dick but he was kind of
cute though at the same time right you
know what I mean so I don't I don't even
like to like offend Animals by calling
people like this animal I've never heard
of it animals are cooler I've never
heard of an animal attacking the
opposite sex of its own species having
sex with it and then killing it I mean
I'm sure it happens but the female
praying mantises will do that well yeah
but they are eating the male the males
kind of [ __ ] sacrificed itself as
caloric intakes so the children could be
born right and and they're not feeling
creatures they're more like robots
so it's it's very different with the
insect world
yeah maybe I should start calling these
people roaches more like insects and
roaches yeah there's some kind of
problem in them they're not humans
obviously they're not I mean yeah and
like I said I'm a big advocate of hey if
you just do like some kind of crimes and
you like [ __ ] I don't really think
that it's
um you know because I think a lot of
people can be rehabilitated I think a
lot of people can be like if you kind of
address like what their problems are if
they have mental health issues or
whatever but I think there is like a
small subset of the population that
absolutely cannot be helped and I think
that a lot of serial killers fall into
that yeah into that uh kind of little
area because it's like
I don't know I think a lot of them are
kind of born like that or born with that
proclivity and then if they have a
[ __ ] up childhood and nobody
intervenes
once they get to their teenage years I
think it's probably too late I think
it's too late
yeah so um okay Brian say hey Tom
starting a new feature today sorry we're
ready to say hi to Jenny hi I'm right
here hey what's up bro
American Military uh 100 said cube is
yeah he that's right he said he um yeah
I think he called it BTK he called it um
cubing cubing that's what he called it
he cubed that [ __ ] away like I said like
putting it in a box in a box yeah I had
forgotten that because yeah cubism I
think of Pablo Picasso yeah [ __ ]
yeah you should you should read that
book I just cubed it away yeah you
should read that book yeah uh you that
[ __ ] would drive me crazy you're yeah
well I read it
I'm just like what the [ __ ] like what
like I knew all about I knew all about
his crimes but it's like it was
something like hearing it from his I'm
still [ __ ] half the way through a
billy Idol's [ __ ] autobiography why
you take so long to read stuff it's
sitting right there in the other room I
gotta [ __ ] finish that [ __ ] up I'm
actually I'm kind of proud of myself I
used to like you read that to me you're
always busy though now yeah I know well
you could probably get an audiobook my
eyes jump around [ __ ] so much on the
line it's hard for me to well the thing
we'll see the best thing about reading
and this is why I don't really like
listening to audiobooks or anything like
that the best thing about reading is
that it makes you concentrate makes you
concentrate you have to concentrate so
that's really good so after my head
injuries I had a hard time [ __ ]
tracking in my eyes across the [ __ ]
lines of a paragraph I'll get about
halfway through the paragraph and then
I'll jump back up to the beginning of
the paragraph I'm like stop it I mean
I've had that happen before too but like
I said you really have to yeah and
honestly like I used to read a lot more
than I do I used to read like [ __ ]
four or five books a week but now I'm
like I read a book a week and I feel
like that's pretty good like considering
all the other stuff I have to do you
know what I mean so
so I try
um okay so let's get back to the thing
uh Zach says Picasso and other artists
might make an interesting show I've been
wanting forever to do a show about
carabaggio but nobody lets me do it like
it never wins like look Caravaggio
murdered somebody he murdered somebody
like it was maybe kind of sort of an
accident but it was still
I don't know like honestly like I read
an um a biography of Caravaggio and it
was called M the man who became because
that wasn't actually his name that was
like the place he was from and um just
like Leonardo da Vinci
and uh that was honestly one of the best
non-fiction books I've ever read it was
fascinating fascinating
he was like a fascinating person like he
was a dick but he was like really a
fascinating person at the same time and
he killed a [ __ ] so you know but
yeah if you're never I can't remember
who wrote it but it's called M the man
who became care about you that was that
was one of my favorite uh non-fiction
books I had a great time reading that
it's massive it's like really big but it
was really good
uh the other one that I really liked was
there was I read a biography of Mozart
too that was really good but I can't
remember what the name of that was but
that was also really good
okay so uh so where were we so these two
[ __ ] they meet in jail and
they're like hey you know it'd be a good
idea what what would be a good idea
um meet like will like abduct and rape
and murder a girl uh that's every year
from like 13 to 19. wouldn't that be fun
yeah that sounds fun yeah that's what
these two [ __ ] are talking
about
so Lawrence bitticker gets paroled uh in
November of 1978 and he goes back to Los
Angeles and he had a job somehow even
though he had like a [ __ ] criminal
record a mile long okay
he gets work like as a machinist or
something like that
so Roy Norris gets let out two months
later in January of 1979. now he moves
in with his mom also in La his mom
worked uh lived in a trailer park so he
moves into the trailer with his Ma
and he gets work as an electrician again
these two [ __ ] like found a job
I don't get how that happened
now at that point like I said like I
said well they didn't have really have
the uh resources back then to like check
because they're like holy crap like your
[ __ ] criminal record is like [ __ ]
as long as my leg
so uh so yeah so he's working as an
electrician now at some point Lawrence
bitticker writes to Roy Norris in
February of 1979 and said hey
um why don't we meet at this hotel you
know how we talked about how we were
going to do this plan with the whole
rape and murder and kidnapping that
let's do that [ __ ] let's do that [ __ ] so
he wants to meet up and like talk about
it like like it's the most normal thing
in the world like I said these are
ah so yeah so they meet up they go have
drinks like it's a normal thing to be
doing
and plan the [ __ ] out what they're gonna
do
so the first thing they do is buy their
rape van
uh so as I said this is a GMC cargo van
not white silver but close enough it was
a 1977 GMC cargo van the thing about it
was that Lawrence was working
um he was a as a machinist and he was
making as far as I could determine a
grand a week in those days which was a
lot of money in the late 19th I mean
[ __ ] that's a lot of money nowadays yeah
that's like way more money than I ever
made yeah
um you know so yeah so he was making a
[ __ ] ton of money
now uh so yeah so they are like okay
we're gonna buy a van and we're gonna
kit it out like for our
project you know if you want to go to
the BTK way his PJ his project that's
what he called it
so yeah so they buy the van and uh
they're like yeah we want one without
any uh side windows yeah windowless fan
and they also really liked the large
sliding door on the passenger side so
they're like hey um you know if we come
up to somebody and they won't get in the
van willingly then all we have to do is
slide open the door and just grab them
and like pull them into the van so you
know win win
that's what they were thinking I mean
they like I said they were very
calculating about all this kind of stuff
they even named the van as I mentioned
earlier and it was named murder Mac the
murder Mac the murder Mac that's what
they called the van okay Jesus Christ
so from February to June of 1979. uh
these two [ __ ]
started cruising up and down the Pacific
Coast Highway now like a lot of serial
killers did they were kind of just like
they weren't killing anybody at first
they were just kind of like doing like
trial runs they were kind of seeing like
what approaches would work the best
so they're kind of like they would drive
the van up and down they would like pick
up hitchhikers and talk to them they're
like hey we got some weed we got some
beer in the back they had a cooler in
the back with beer in it stuff like that
they were trying to like determine the
best way to get people into the van
you know so they'd kind of like they'd
go hang out at the beach they'd flirt
with girls and see like what worked and
what didn't work so as I said they were
very very calculating in the way they
wanted to go about this and
um early on too they would also take a
lot of photos like they had a Polaroid
it's funny the [ __ ] probably
could have just got laid just that they
were just being normal well they didn't
want that though clearly they didn't
want that that's not what they were
looking for right exactly right so I
kind of feel like that's
yeah they everything was in service this
is amazing
of their goal it's like we want to rape
and kill somebody because that's how
they would get off so it wasn't like
they could just like flirt with a girl
it's like oh I like her and yeah we got
girlfriends now you can have a van and I
can have a van and we can [ __ ] go to
the [ __ ] like a normal [ __ ] person
yeah like a normal [ __ ] person
[ __ ] crazy these two were not normal
[ __ ] people obviously
so um yeah so they were just picking up
people and just seeing what they could
do seeing what they could get away with
and seeing what the best methods were
for getting people into the van or
whatnot
um and they would also like they had a
Polaroid and they would take pictures
like they'd be like hey can we take your
picture and they take a picture of like
the Polaroid now later on like after
these [ __ ] got caught
um they found like 500 Polaroids like in
one of their houses
um and they don't actually know who a
lot of those women are I don't think a
lot of them were killed
um because like I said they said that
they just did a lot of practice runs and
they were just going around not killing
anybody at first but they were just
taking pictures just seeing what they
could do you know what I mean
so finally they're like okay
they figure out we need a place to like
take the victims so they're thinking a
lot about this obviously so they found
this place which was like really really
isolated now it was kind of behind it
was like one of those um like a fire
Road where they have like the the gate
across it with the lock like you're not
really supposed to drive back there so
they found one of those I think it was
in the um the San Gabriel mountains okay
now what they did was because they had
all the tools in the van
uh they actually cut through the lock
and then they bought their own lock and
put it back on the thing so it's like so
it wouldn't look weird if anybody was
just looking at it funny but it was
their lock you know what I'm saying so
it was patrolled much people weren't I
guess not yeah well that's why they were
kind of like going around like looking
for a really isolated area so that's not
a way to go around it
that way you didn't have to [ __ ] [ __ ]
with the lock at all but okay go ahead
maybe like I said maybe they wanted a
really air like an area where people
wouldn't disturb them and also an area
where nobody would like think about its
owns you would think somebody would have
[ __ ] checked that lock ever and
patrolled that [ __ ] but I guess not I
guess I mean this was the 70s so I guess
not
so yeah so they're like okay well that's
they got all that they got the van they
got the van all set up they built a bed
into the van with like a space
underneath they're like okay we can put
a cooler under there like I said with
like beer and soda and [ __ ] like that
they had marijuana so they could like
lure people in with that and it's like
oh and if we need to we can like stash
bodies like underneath it was like they
thought about this like very very which
is [ __ ] up I mean they were like this
was their plan dude seriously have
better goals I'm just saying so so yeah
so they did that
so they had everything set up it's like
this is the place we're gonna take it
it's like it's all locked up it's really
private everything like that so now we
just need a victim
so then they start going out looking for
one now the first one that they found
sadly was June 24th 1979.
now later on Lawrence Whitaker said to
the cops oh the day started out
innocently enough God
throat does he unfortunately he's dead
now now um what he would do sometimes
when they were going out like on the
hunt which like I said they had been
doing like uh previously he would sleep
in the van outside of because Roy lived
with his mom in the trailer you know in
the trailer park
so a lot of times like Lawrence would
park the van in front of the trailer and
then he would sleep in the van and then
obviously would sleep in the house like
with his mom he's not sleeping with his
mom as far as I know but you know that
would just be icing on the cake but if
he was sleeping with his mom
so uh so yeah so they're working on the
bed that morning uh you know like I said
and then about 11 o'clock in the morning
they're like um it was a Sunday so
they're like we're gonna go cruise
around the beach we're gonna see if we
can like you know we're gonna smoke some
weed we're gonna drink some beer drive
around listen to the radio you know
Sunny Sunday in uh [ __ ] in the summer
and gonna flirt with some girls and see
what we can see so they decided to do
that
so they kind of like drive all around
they Drive North they're kind of like
stopping here and there Redondo Beach
Santa Monica yada yada they're keeping
an eye out they're specifically looking
for female hitchhikers or anybody that
looked like they would get in the van
like willingly so sometimes they would
even like park the van and they'd walk
around like the beach on foot like
looking for prospects and [ __ ] like that
so they were doing that like pretty much
all day
now when they were driving around though
it was like it was evening at this point
it was like 5 P.M
so they're in Redondo Beach and then
they found uh a girl oh my goodness
Pookie yeah what are you doing
there's Pookie she's like yeah
what do you want to talk to the lights
talk to everybody
she's like no oh baby girl
she's like okay she just puts up with it
yeah
she's like all right at least I'm good
yeah she's having fun at least I'm
getting petted yeah but uh but yeah so
so they're doing that kind of [ __ ] and
then so this girl she was 16 years old
uh Lucinda Cindy Schaefer better known
as Cindy
so she was apparently just walking
around like walking to the beach or
walking down the street or whatever and
uh so apparently one of the dudes they
are they St they argued about like which
one it was but it's like hey look at
that cute little blonde over there these
two dudes were like I don't even know if
they're middle-aged at this time but
they were clearly much much older than
16. this is a 16 year old girl for
Christ's sake and they're just kind of
like hey let's that'll be the first one
for our game you know we don't know how
old she is but she's clearly a teenager
uh so she was actually walking back to
her grandmother's house she'd been at a
Christian Youth meeting at a
Presbyterian Church nearby and was just
like walking back to her Grandma's house
just walking on the street
so the van murder Mac uh pulls up next
to her and says hey want to ride and
she's like [ __ ] no I mean she probably
didn't say [ __ ] no that's what I would
have said but she was like uh yeah no
thank you because you know rape van
but uh so it kept so she just kept
walking and like ignoring it and then
they just kept following her
and she was probably like freaking out
at this point so then like the van like
pulls up ahead and like pulls into a
driveway like in front of her
and then Roy gets out and pretends he's
like farting around like inside the van
like oh I'm getting something out of the
van yada yada and then he turns around
like when he sees her he's like hey you
sure you don't want that ride blah blah
like smiling at her and she's just like
ignores like [ __ ] [ __ ] you creepy weirdo
and like I said she was [ __ ] right
about that
so she tries to walk past and Roy
grabbed her and threw her into the van
uh at which point they slammed the
sliding door and turned the radio up all
the way so that it would muffle and he
screams uh so basically that was another
thing that they had planned now uh she
fought him obviously but he was a lot
bigger than her she was just 16 years
old and he uh kind of like put duct tape
over her mouth and bound her wrists and
ankles and one shoe was left behind on
the sidewalk because they basically just
snatched her off the [ __ ] sidewalk
now uh this is [ __ ] up but I thought
uh that I would add it
Lauren Spinnaker later said that Cindy
set and this is a quote from something
that he wrote throughout the whole
experience Cindy displayed a magnificent
magnificent state of self-control and
composed acceptance of the conditions
and facts over which she had no control
ah
she shed no tears offered no resistance
and expressed no great concern for her
safety I guess she knew what was coming
hmm
that might be a pretty cold analysis of
what would happen
she was just like okay I see I mean she
seemed to fight at first but I don't
know if this is true because this dude I
don't really necessarily want to believe
anything this [ __ ] says because
he was a [ __ ] lunatic but I mean
maybe she was just well [ __ ] that's
gonna happen and maybe she was
calculating herself I was like how the
[ __ ] can I get out of this yeah that's
probably what it was it was just kind of
like
and maybe I want to say too that once
you've accepted that what's going to
happen like they don't want to give the
[ __ ] the satisfaction I mean I
kind of feel like that's the way I would
yeah also part of it look I'm gonna
[ __ ] go to a [ __ ] cartel video I
watch [ __ ] I got friends down in
Mexico send me videos of [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] that's happened
the cartels got a whole they had a
[ __ ] female who was she was a rat and
they were just like she's telling on us
and [ __ ] this is what happens blah
blah they cut her head off with a
[ __ ] probably about a four inch
pocket knife they don't use guns they
have them but they don't use guns or any
impressive weapons they want you to know
they can kill you with something
like you'd find out of your kitchen
and they cut her head off starting from
the back
okay not the front because they tried to
keep her alive as long as possible
and man what got me about that video is
that she just grinned and bared it she
didn't give them a [ __ ] itch and they
cut her head off and she didn't even
[ __ ] flinch
like I said I kind of feel like she's
just like you don't want to get into
that you don't want to give him the
[ __ ] you know what it's gonna happen
and it's like after a time you're just
like okay well this is gonna happen so
you don't want to give them the
satisfaction of like being scared of
them or giving them what they want I
guess maybe that's what it was right so
don't imagine the [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
in a horror movie Type of Way a lot of
times the the person that's being killed
resists any way they possibly can
uh which Kudos I do this [ __ ] same
thing
but [ __ ] no I saw that video of that
girl getting her head coach woman you
know getting her head cut off she didn't
give them [ __ ] an inch
I was I was kind of impressed I was like
God damn
I was barely able to watch them I mean I
don't think I'd be able to like but but
the thing about it though is that
I don't know and like I said if you want
to [ __ ] scream your head off and
fight and everything like that like
that's good too I mean you could also do
that but I kind of feel I'm the kind of
[ __ ] that I'm just like well I
know you want me to like be scream
scream and be scared of you so I'm not
gonna yeah that's what that's that's
what this woman I'm not gonna she was
like go ahead cut my head off I'm good
[ __ ] yeah cause then you don't get the
satisfaction right I mean they probably
still do it but you know what I mean
they're gonna do it anyway with her
teeth they're gonna do it anyway they're
gonna do it anyway she just gritted her
teeth and [ __ ] looked at it my
[ __ ] cut yeah it's like yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah which like I said I
you know I admire that I admire that but
like I said if you want to [ __ ]
scream if I do that too
but yeah so at this point yeah so they
get her in the van she's all tied up and
she can't scream or anything like that
because they have like duct tape over
her mouth so they drive to their little
fire Road and you know get open their
lock and everything like that so they
Park you know out hidden like because
you can't see them from the road
so the dudes are like smoking weed and
kind of and then they're like asking her
about her family like they're asking her
like all these weird questions and stuff
like that
and then
um because this is their first one you
know what I mean they've been doing it
like they've been practicing for a long
time but this was like the first one so
I don't really know what was going
through their heads if anything
so they asked her a bunch of questions
for you know a little while and then
they're like okay uh take your clothes
off and then at that point like Lawrence
uh you know he raped her first so he's
like tells Roy hey why don't you go take
off for an hour so you know you and then
they would switch out you know what I
mean so [ __ ]
um so yeah so they're taking turns and
basically okay so there's kind of like
differing because all we have is these
two [ __ ]
um you know stories about what happened
now Roy said that he was at because they
said that they argued for a while over
whether they should kill her or not
um and after they decided that they
would Roy said that he
started to strangle her
but he couldn't do it or he wasn't doing
it right or something like that and he
was like freaked out by it and had to
like run around to the front of the van
and like throw up
um so then he said and like I said don't
take this at face value because this
dude could probably just like make him
be making [ __ ] up like to save his own
ass because we'll get into that but he's
like oh I had a hard time and I had to
go around and throw up and then when I
got back
um Lawrence was choking her but she was
still alive like she was still still
jerking he said and at that point like
Lawrence
um he gave Roy like uh like a wire coat
hanger and they twisted around her neck
like to strangle her with it and what
they would do is they would take the um
the thing and they would like and they
would do it with the pliers like they
would tighten with the pliers
who knows
okay
so yeah sure if I buy that story well I
don't know like I said this is just from
there you know no one else was there
obviously
so after she died they wrapped her body
up in a plastic shower curtain and then
they uh they picked her up and they took
her the one of the reasons that they
chose this location was because there
was a lot of like deep canyons in the
area and Lawrence bitticker I believe
was the one that said oh well we can
just throw them like over a canyon like
the animals will eat them and nobody
will ever find them so it's fine
so that's basically what they did
um they took her body and they threw her
off cliff
so you know they said hey animals will
eat it it'll all be fine
now uh so they're like well that was fun
but um next time we should probably like
keep something from the victim because
that would be like did they ever find
her body
some of the bodies they found some of
them they did did they find that one's
body
um I don't remember if that one was one
of the ones they found but um I don't
think it was I think they found two or
three of the bodies but a couple of them
they never did but that girl did end up
missing and who that was yes yes yes
look at you pookie yeah look at her look
at her little face look at you sweet pea
yeah she likes all that interaction she
wants to be in the constant center of
attention yeah she's one of the like she
really really likes for you to get all
up in her face and all up in her she
doesn't mind when you like yeah see kiss
on her she don't care it like gets like
rubbing on her like a lot of times I'll
like lay on her little back and she'll
be like whatever yeah she's like funny
like that and she I'll just be trying to
sleep and she's [ __ ] with me when I'm
asleep
it's all day like this yeah yeah yeah
she's she's very uh she's an interactive
cat yeah she really really likes it just
be all up in your face like all the time
she'll be right back in 20 minutes watch
probably yeah
John Gore said I don't think I could
watch one of those cartel videos it
would [ __ ] me up for a long time it's
like I don't I don't really want to
necessarily like I I can imagine it I I
have a really vivid imagination so the
cartels are now I don't I don't need to
watch that because I can imagine what it
would look like and I'm sure I would
never scrub that from some of the ones
they sent me they got the dude and he's
[ __ ] basically nailed down to a
[ __ ]
wooden [ __ ] table so you can't move
and they got him [ __ ] hooked up with
IVs and [ __ ] to keep him alive and
[ __ ] they're pumping blood into him
and they've skinned him alive
[ __ ] bored his eyes out cut his
tongue out they're just taking pieces of
him apart while he's alive and they're
videotaping it and they're streaming
that [ __ ] sending it and they'll put it
up on
Mexican Facebook to let everybody know
what they're doing
um and Matt and Facebook is afraid to
put take it down in Mexico because they
said we know where you're employees live
and if you take our [ __ ] down we'll come
after him
so leave it up for a certain amount of
time then they'll take it down
just like if you watch the movie [ __ ]
Apocalypse Now
terrorism ain't [ __ ] that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
horrorism is a whole new thing horrorism
works
[ __ ] you could horrify a [ __ ]
State and a corporation into obedience
and the [ __ ] Mexican cartels have it
down to a size
and some of this should be studied
because
as Western Civilization collapses you're
going to see more of that that will rise
to the top because that's a dominant
philosophy
you do what we say or we do this to your
child because they do it to people's
kids
it works
is it good no it's not work but whoever
told you that [ __ ] whoever told you
that good wins [ __ ] are bad
and um you can even bring a a nation or
a
Corporation to its knees they're
terrified
horrified
Rebecca said having my first coffee of
the day yeah she's in Australia so it's
morning there uh so I'm in boring mode
until the magic Bean Juice hydrates my
sarcasm these two [ __ ] stains I've heard
of before I hope they died a painful
miserable death I do too it's like they
died of old age but man I hope they had
[ __ ] hemorrhoids and cancer and
[ __ ] everything Jesus Christ
Sebastian says reality is worse than
horror films yeah that's true I'd rather
put a bullet in my head than surrender
to them awful situation to be in yeah
that's the thing I just kind of I don't
know
I don't know what I would do like I've
never been in this situation thankfully
but
and I'm not like [ __ ] on anybody's
reaction because you never know like how
you're gonna react to stuff until you're
actually in that situation most serial
rapists don't kill the victim and it's
kind of what they do is kind of like
this
that's why a lot of women surrender
because most of them are surviving
but you never know that's what I'm
saying you never know and honestly I
kind of feel like
I don't know it's like they always said
like I remember when I was in school
we had like a program where somebody
came in and was talking about like rape
prevention and stuff like that and I'm
like well but you can't apply all that
stuff like right across the board
because you don't know who you're
dealing with right you don't know like
is this a cereal because this [ __ ]
Ted Bundy that's gonna cut my head off
and like [ __ ] my severed head they're
used for using roses and [ __ ] so that's
what I'm saying so it's like I don't
really know and it's like you don't
really know what the [ __ ] you're dealing
with so it's like should I just Jesus
Christ
come
oh my God it's like should you just kind
of like go along with it which you know
that's really not my nature but should
you just go along with it and like hope
they let you go or should you just fight
if maybe they'll kill you because
they'll get mad it's like you don't
really you don't know what you're
dealing with so I kind of feel like any
situation any kind of like advice that
you would give people across the board
that's not gonna work because you don't
really know what you're dealing with
maybe in some cases if you fight back
they'll be like oh [ __ ] that it's too
much trouble but then maybe in some
cases if you fight back it'll just make
a mad and then they'll end up killing
you where they wouldn't have otherwise
so you don't really you don't really
know there there's nothing that applies
across the board in this situation with
these two sub-humans
um I'm not really sure
I don't think there's anything you could
have done I don't think there's anything
you could have done like once they got
you into their clutches I kind of feel
like
anything you did it was just going to be
like they were going to kill you
regardless so I'm not really sure that
anything you did was gonna make a
difference which is sad but you don't
know when you're gonna like get it and
the thing about it that's scary to me is
that these two [ __ ] they went
around like picking up hitchhikers and
like flirting with girls on the beach
and stuff like that like for a long time
before they actually like went of like
oh this is the one we're gonna kill so
it's like you don't know you could have
just been like some random girl and it's
like you found these dudes like hey we
got some weed and you hung out in their
van for a little while and nothing
happened to you but then later you find
out that these [ __ ] were the
same people that like killed all these
other women like in the same situation
so you never know
you just gotta everything is like
context you just have to kind of like
worry about whatever's happening in the
moment because sometimes if you fight
it's better sometimes if you don't fight
it's better and you don't really know
until you're in that situation because
every situation is different you know
what I mean it's just kind of like Jesus
Christ
alt account says I'm on live I usually
just watch because Tom and Jenny never
answer me what are you talking about we
never answer you who are you who are you
[Laughter]
uh alt accounts that I don't see Rebecca
or Sebastian in my blog well you're not
blocked because I see you so I don't I
don't really know
uh Rebecca says real quickly because the
coffee thing y'all mentioned maple
flavored syrup with zero sugar is good
in coffee so I bought some last night oh
my God this stuff is so good thank you
very much that's right when are you
gonna like make me some with that yeah
whenever you ask you make your coffee up
here so make me some yeah maple syrup
man
I just have regular ass yeah good and
coffee
and I only have Aunt Jemima too with
with the sugar in it and everything
nothing wrong with Aunt Jemima yeah
that's why he's always used to eat on my
pancakes
but yeah so oh my God okay so we still
have a lot to go through yeah so let's
so let's get on before I get like too
drunk
okay
so they've killed one one percent and
now they're all excited about it so like
oh we're gonna do this again so you have
to think too that the women that they
killed this was in a very short time
period this was like a five month period
in 1979. so this wasn't like a long
extended like over years and years like
oh we'll pick off a victim like once a
year or some [ __ ] like that this was a
lot of victims in a pretty short time
so they go out again July 8th 1979 and
uh so they see this girl hitchhiking on
the Pacific Coast Highway
now they were behind this is crazy but
they were behind the car or like a few
cars behind the car that actually picked
her up like she was hitchhiking they're
like oh there you go we'll pick that
girl up and then like but a white
convertible that was a couple cars ahead
of them pulled over and picked her up
and they were like well [ __ ] now what do
we do
so they're kind of like cranky about it
but
um Lawrence is like oh well we'll just
follow them and then we'll see like
wherever she gets let off then we'll
pick her up so it'll all work out so
they follow the convertible for a little
while so they were committed to this
[ __ ]
so the driver of the convertible who had
picked up the girl she uh you know they
they signaled for like an exit ramp and
they you know put the brakes and they
let the girl off
and they let her out like on the side of
the road
so at that point she goes to hitchhike
again so she sticks her thumb back out
waiting for the next ride to get to
wherever she was going
so basically okay so what they decided
to do was that Roy said he was he had
been sitting in the passenger seat
because Lawrence was driving of you know
the the murder van murder Mack whatever
the [ __ ] they call it
so he says well to look less
I don't know if this is like more creepy
or less creepy I don't know it's it's
creepy either way but he's like well I'm
gonna
um he hid under the raised bed in the
back of the van he says like well it
will be less scary if it's one dude
driving a van rather than two dudes and
I was like is it like even even one dude
I don't know like any number of dudes in
a windowless van is suspect I don't care
how many dudes you have in this one dude
it's two dudes it's three dudes it's
five dudes I'm not getting in there I'm
sorry I'm just not so I don't know it's
like one or two it's it just seems like
a I don't know that seems like an
intellectual question it's it's both bad
so yeah so he says well maybe it'll seem
less intimidating if I if there's not
two dudes so he hides under the bed
so uh so basically uh yeah Andrea Hall
was 18 years old that was the girl that
was hitchhiking
and again she was hitchhiking so they
pulled over and she was like okay cool I
need a ride so she gets in the passenger
seat they pull back into traffic uh he
says hey it's hot out you want a cold
drink she's like sure why not because
like I said they have a cooler there
with all kinds of sodas and beer and
stuff like that which they they've also
planned ahead for
so at this point Andrea goes to get a
drink from the cooler in the van
uh and then Roy jumps out from under the
bed
and kind of swept your legs out from
underneath her and then they start
fighting like in the back of the of the
van
and again like Lawrence like turns the
music way up so nobody hears anything
like struggling or Screaming or anything
like that
um again Andrea like [ __ ] fought
obviously but you know it was a dude he
was a lot bigger than her so you know
basically he just bound her wrists and
ankles and covered her mouth up with
tape
so they drove her to the fire road with
their lock on it and they basically they
didn't even talk to her this time it's
just I feel like the first time they
were like asking her questions because
maybe I don't know they didn't know what
they were doing they were experimenting
about what they liked and [ __ ] like that
this time they're like oh we didn't want
to talk to this one so they basically
just started raping her which is you
know whatever
so they so they raped her a bunch of
times both of them like taking turns
and then uh they put some film in the
Polaroid and then they dragged Andrea
out of the van
uh Roy went down to the convenience
store to get some more beer because
that's what you do yeah yeah when you're
doing this kind of crap
and uh so then he's basically so when
he's gone like Lawrence is just there
taking a bunch of pictures of Andrea
doing a photo shoot yeah yeah and her
face is like all [ __ ] up like
obviously she's [ __ ] terrified
they're beating her up and he was
getting off on it yeah
are the photos still around
God I don't know probably but it's like
I don't know if I wanna I'm sure I don't
want to see them Jesus Christ but
I don't know if they are I'm like I'm
sure they were
they found a bunch of Polaroids like
after these [ __ ] were caught
but I don't know if these were among
them right okay I mean I think they were
but so I'm sure you can probably find
them but I was not gonna go look for
them Jesus Christ I don't I don't want
that in my [ __ ] brain Yeah so
basically like what Lawrence would do
this is one of the things that really
like
um
Disturbed me about this [ __ ]
so Lawrence says to Andrea
um
so I'm gonna kill you
give me as many reasons as you can
as to why I shouldn't do that like why
you should be allowed to live
so obviously she's like having she's
like well Jesus Christ like what the
[ __ ] like you can't come up with
anything in that situation but he's just
like [ __ ] with her I mean he's gonna
kill her anyway obviously
so she can't really come up with
anything or doesn't come up with
anything that satisfies him I guess
um so he starts sticking an ice pick
into her ear like into her brain damn
then he turns her over and sticks the
ice picket in the other ear and the
other side of her didn't kill her yeah
and then Stomps on the handle of the ice
pick
putting it further and further into her
brain
until the handle broke
so then like Lawrence then strangled her
with his so that didn't even kill her no
no
yeah and that happens again like later
on so buck up
so then he like uh yeah he strangled her
and then threw her body off a cliff just
like the other well these dudes look
[ __ ] man
that's kind of there's kind of a common
misconception that if you penetrate
somebody with some kind of Spike or
something small diameter that kills them
it doesn't
always you can you can stab somebody
even with a [ __ ] serious knife
[ __ ] 20 30 [ __ ] 60 times and it
doesn't kill him
you know it's hard to kill somebody
that's why I always laugh like a [ __ ]
what it was it was the ice ice pick yeah
ice picks too damn surgical that's not
displacing enough stuff
you know there's not a bleeding I mean I
mean relative I mean obviously basically
a big needle you don't want that to
happen no you don't want it to happen
kill you it won't kill you but it
probably won't kill you yeah well and
that's the thing like you kind of see a
lot of stuff in movies I kind of always
laugh like when they show in movies like
somebody gets stabbed in the back like
one time and they fall over dead I'm
like yeah no that's not how that I'm
like that person would absolutely
survive and they would they would
probably be fine like they got a couple
stitches and you didn't said earlier you
didn't hit any major organs you're fine
I had a friend of mine was [ __ ]
stabbed like [ __ ] five or six times
or four or five times up in the upper
body with a [ __ ] four or five inch
blade in a bar fight he lived he'd even
go to the hospital
he couldn't go to the hospital he was at
blame he would have gone to jail over
that [ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm sure like that
like happens all the time I'm sure that
happens all the times all the time well
and honestly like I've I've written
about some cases where people like some
victims got stabbed like multiple times
and survived it's like it wasn't a fun
time for them but they recovered like
they were okay like after that as long
as infection doesn't get you a [ __ ]
sure like if you get to a hospital in in
a reasonable amount of time uh alt
account says hello y'all I'm watching
okay but you have to tell me who you are
though because I it says YouTube
blocking LMAO thanks for saying hello
Yeah we're not really sure who you are
because I'm not sure if you're naming
yourself alt account because you got
kicked off of YouTube for some reason
but it's like you know it's it's fine we
see you you're not blocked we see
everybody's uh comments lion X Warrior
said I have a morbid belief that the 70s
and 80s has a plethora of Unsolved cold
cases it really does seem to
it really does seem to and we've talked
about this before I kind of feel like
the 70s and 80s
I have a theory man I yeah I kind of
feel like I don't know if this is the
case because I kind of feel like prior
to
uh you know more technological advances
in forensic science I kind of feel like
yeah a lot of more crimes were solved
like from a statistical standpoint but
how many of those people were just like
wrongfully convicted because they didn't
really have the technology to say like
oh it wasn't this guy or wasn't that guy
oh well somebody saw this guy at the
scene so we're gonna arrest them and
hang them or whatever and that crime is
like solved so I get that but 70s and
80s did really seem to see a a
significant spike in these types of
crimes and one of Tom's theories and I
don't think and I think this is a
significant factor I'm not I don't think
it's the only Factor but I think it's
significant is lead gasoline I think so
yeah lead gasoline because lead maybe
you [ __ ] if you don't know like yeah
it'll [ __ ] with your uh your frontal
cortex yeah
which kind of takes away your uh
inhibition to kind of say it takes away
all that kind of stuff also over his IQ
yeah your lower side Q awesome so I kind
of feel like I don't think that's the
only Factor but I think that was
absolutely a significant I remember
leading gasoline
I do too vaguely I remember [ __ ]
pumping it into my [ __ ] car
vaguely and uh the smell of it and
yeah there was a kind of a slight high
around gasoline at that time
and but I you know I wasn't I didn't
live in
I wasn't living [ __ ] full time and
really densely populated areas where
[ __ ] lead particles would be around
for a long period of time
but I could I could imagine it
I remember smog in California
you don't see smog anymore
smog would [ __ ] you up man give you a
[ __ ] terrible [ __ ] I remember
everybody this would be [ __ ] it
wasn't bad in Florida but I remember
everybody complaining about it like in
California particularly and like some of
the big cities like oh it's like look at
this soupy sky today yeah when you were
a kid it would [ __ ] cause your eyes
to water a lot of irritation and it
would [ __ ] make your ears ring and uh
[ __ ] make you light-headed so and as
a little kid I remembered it so there's
no telling what it was doing to those
adults they were in it for a long period
of time brain damage wouldn't wouldn't
surprise me that yeah that wouldn't
surprise me at all yeah like I said I
don't think that's the only Factor but I
think that's a pretty significant factor
yeah I mean the ancient Romans are
drinking out of damn lead pipes and they
did crazy [ __ ] too
so wouldn't surprise me if it was
[ __ ] lead that did a lot of this Zack
said it's interesting to me how it seems
like the mass shooter has kind of
replaced serial killer in terms of the
thing that gets all the public attention
in a way I kind of feel like it's those
are two different pathologies I feel
like but in a way I kind of feel like
the mass shooter situation is more
Taylor I know this is a weird thing to
say but it might be more tailored toward
the internet age because it's kind of
like it's kind of like please don't take
this the wrong way but it's kind of like
the lazy way of killing a bunch of
people like if you're a serial killer a
lot of those [ __ ] uh operated
over a long time like months or years or
something like that and they planned and
so and I'm not saying that like an
admirable way and the motive is
different the motive was sexual I kind
of feel like the mass shooter thing is
like we want like as much attention as
quickly as possible with the least
amount of effort with the least amount
of effort and it's a different as I said
it's a different pathology I kind of
feel like serial killers they're more
into like the long term we like the hunt
we like it's almost kind of like a like
a predator that's you know hunting
people they get off on even if they
don't
kill the thing like BTK there was a
bunch of projects that he was working on
that he never did like he but he stalked
several people at one time and Drew up
all these elaborate plans how am I going
to get into the house and how many like
he got off on that
Mass Shooters I kind of feel like that's
more of like that's a different I mean
it's still [ __ ] up and you it's you
know the damage is still the same
because you're still killing you know a
comparable amount of people but it's a
different motivation I kind of feel like
they're more
it's more anger it's more self-loathing
it's more that kind of [ __ ] it's more
attention whoring it's more of that kind
of stuff right because a a Serial sexual
sexual serial killer
he did he wanted to be known but he
didn't want to be caught not until he
was [ __ ] really sick of what he was
doing
okay he wanted to be operating for a
long time and he wanted to be famous for
what he was doing the [ __ ]
Mass shooter it's a flash in the pan
it's all happening at one time they want
their Fame right now
I kind of feel like it's I mean it's I
think it's instructive that a lot of
mass Shooters are young men or like
teenage boys or like guys in their 20s
and they're betas they're always always
betas well they're all betas on both
sides but it's a different it's a
different form of gratification
[ __ ] the serial killer sees himself
as some kind of connoisseur or an expert
that he's special
uh Mass murderers no not really
they uh they their grandstanding
[ __ ] attention [ __ ]
you're gonna do it all in one shot well
and you have somebody like you know some
[ __ ] like Elliot Roger or
somebody like that we did a show about
who he kind of felt like oh well the
world owed him yeah and the reason and
because the world wasn't giving him what
he felt he deserved which is entitlement
um that he was gonna punish people that
didn't have [ __ ] all to do with him at
all another thing is is that there's a
there's a misconception that this is a
new phenomenon not really no it's not
these guys have always been around
just there wasn't as many of them
because the population wasn't as large
well like I said even if there were you
didn't hear about them as much because
there was like a national or
International media where you would hear
about this stuff like
you know so if something happened yeah
it's 17 and 1800s had School shooters
and everything they had all that well
that's what I'm saying like sometimes
when I look back to like research crimes
that happen like you know late 19th
century early 20th century there's a lot
of stuff that went on back then that
note that didn't really catch on because
it was more like a local thing right and
even though maybe locally people were
like holy [ __ ] this really [ __ ] up
like ax murder or whatever it was like
happened but it didn't really get any
traction and on national scale so it
didn't like take off from that point and
then like after like more [ __ ] happened
and people forgot about it so don't
think that the [ __ ] that happens
nowadays because I know that some people
have a thing it's like oh my God like
all this horrible [ __ ] happens nowadays
I'm like this horrible [ __ ] that's been
happening forever it's always been
happening it's just you didn't hear
about it as much back then now you hear
about if if some [ __ ] happens in [ __ ]
it Uzbekistan somewhere yeah like you
know with some really [ __ ] up serial
killer you're gonna hear about it
because it's gonna be on the internet
back in the old days you wouldn't have
heard about that right you know it was
so it would have seemed
[ __ ] goes back to ancient Rome two
thousand years ago probably ancient
Egypt
that all this stuff happened
the Freer the society the more likely it
was to happen also
if it wasn't a very free Society doesn't
happen that much because they don't the
people don't have freedom of movement
like uh North Korea as far as we know
doesn't they don't have serial killers
they have rapists but they don't have
serial killers they're not you couldn't
do that there you don't have freedom of
movement but it's a totalitarian Society
so everything's a trade-off the thing
about it is that even if they did have
them would they let anybody know I won't
let anybody know that's what I'm saying
so they so there absolutely might be
[ __ ] like that going on yeah but they're
keeping a real tight little we wouldn't
know about it that's what I'm saying
right so I kind of feel like it's not so
much that oh my God it happened so much
more often yeah I just think it's like
that we have now a global media so you
hear about stuff that happens in very
far among countries whereas before you
would only hear about stuff that
happened locally or like within 50 100
miles of you here and so it probably
seemed much safer here's an example I
just brought up a couple days ago about
the old west the old west was relatively
peaceful
in in many ways the the the [ __ ]
population density was very low okay
there was violence but per capita wasn't
that bad it's probably less than what
you'd have today
and when you looked at likes in the old
west some of the biggest events would be
like to shoot out at the okay Corral all
right that's really that really ain't
[ __ ] by today's standards if you were to
look at say like Chicago
that
kind of [ __ ] happens to Chicago every
[ __ ] week but you don't hear about it
okay
it has to do with population density is
a lot of it and [ __ ] what the Norms
are
yeah over in Chicago you have dudes that
have [ __ ] shootout [ __ ] four or
five guys get killed that's it no big
deal
but because that happened in the old
west between the clintons and the
[ __ ] what would you call it [ __ ]
it's kind of it it's an immortal
shootout now
but if you were to actually put it in
today's standards there's not much to
that
you know
yeah but like I said the reason that it
sticks out was because probably
yeah [ __ ] like that was going on because
like I said I started looking at it for
example like the Villisca ax murder and
when I was looking into that it's like
there was a [ __ ] ton of other horrible
ax murders that happened like all around
the country yeah at that time but like
nobody remembers though please remember
yeah they don't remember those like
whole family's wiped out and here here's
the thing this is what I'm trying to try
to reassure you [ __ ] okay cover your
own back make sure you're protected
that's the [ __ ] main thing don't
worry it
is
it's bad but it was always bad well the
thing about it is that as you're
thinking that it was because you can
blow that [ __ ] up into proportions
honestly there was always weird [ __ ]
going that's what I'm saying I'm not
saying that like bad [ __ ] can happen to
you obviously like any any random person
could get killed by a terrorist or a
serial killer or anything like that but
statistically
it happening to you specifically is very
very very very unlikely yeah so don't
like live your entire like cover your
ass but don't live your entire life like
afraid of it because
99.99 it's not gonna happen yeah it's
not gonna happen and the statistics of
violence goes up and down
the last real high Spike was 1970s that
was a very final I think 89 was the
highest as far like that's what I
remember like from my research 89 but
then it started going like precipitous
even with all the crazy [ __ ] happening
today no it's it's nowhere near as
violent as it was no and I think a lot
of it had to do with [ __ ] leaded
gasoline uh people's inhibitions were
lowered and [ __ ] people were crazy
that's what I mean it's like you guys if
you guys were not around in the 70s and
80s and it's just kind of like yeah and
it wasn't even even in the 70s and 80s
as bad as it was you didn't really know
it it well you did but it wasn't as bad
as it's been some other times I'm just
saying that nowadays like people piss
and moan about like oh crime this and
that I'm just like yeah there's always
been crime but it's nothing nothing like
it was back then yeah not even close
like right not even close like right now
there's a spike in crime happening in
New York City
it's still not as bad as it was no way
it's not even close it's not even close
yeah that's what I'm saying so it's like
quit [ __ ] worrying about me yeah
honestly the stress will kill you faster
than a serial killer world that's what I
always kind of feel so I'm not saying
yeah you could get super super unlucky
and get killed by a serial killer I'm
not saying that couldn't happen it's
possible I'm just saying that it's
really really really really
statistically unlikely statistically
unlikely
and as I said the 70s and 80s
were bad but
even then
most of most people were still okay it
was still okay
you know but all right so we'll get back
to talking about this
so
yeah so they killed Andrea Hall
uh so there was that with the whole ice
pick thing
so their third victim that Lawrence and
uh Roy
made uh this was Labor Day September 3rd
1979.
so they're driving around in Murder Mac
their little rape van uh through Hermosa
Beach
and they see two girls who are sitting
on a bench at a bus stop
now these two girls were 15 year old
Jackie Gilliam
and 13 year old Jacqueline Leah Camp I
believe that Leah Camp went by her
middle name which was Leah her first
name was Jacqueline
now they weren't actually waiting for a
bus they were just sitting at the bus
stop uh but they I don't know they were
just kind of like hanging out like I
said they were just kids back in the 70s
you know just hanging out
so they pull up and say hey want to ride
so the two little girls are sort of like
uh sure why not and they're just kind of
like we you know we're not going
anywhere in particular we're just kind
of like hanging out
so they get in the van now uh they offer
some some offer them some weed and the
girls are just kind of like hey okay
cool free weed whatever
so they start passing the joint around
and uh so at this point like Lawrence
who usually drove I feel like uh he says
oh we're going to the beach
but then he's driving and then Jackie
and Leah are like um hey bro you are
driving away from the beach you're
actually going north like toward the
mountains so what the [ __ ] is the deal
this isn't the way the beach is
um he's like oh no it's fine um I'm just
looking for a place to park so we can
you know finish getting high or whatever
so the girls are like yeah we don't like
this and they park next to like this
kind of tennis court like in a Suburban
neighborhood kind of thing
now at this point like both Leah and
Jackie are like yeah [ __ ] this we're out
of here thank you arrazo erased away 15
thank you very much Jenny are there
going to be any more additions of the
faceless villain I've been working on a
volume four but I haven't really had
time to like get much to it I have like
two or three chapters of it written but
I don't know when I'm gonna finish it
because I just I don't have time to like
[ __ ] so that's a yes but eventually
yeah but eventually yeah but eventually
I I have started one but I don't know
how long it's gonna be before I finish
it
um
says uh I recently started reading about
serial killers the former USSR in 70s
80s yikes who would have thought yeah I
mean I kind of feel like 70s and 80s
were like the Heyday like from late 70s
to like late 80s like that 20-year
period I that was like when the biggest
Spike was like I said Hawaiian Warriors
says per capita in the mid-1800s were
off the off the hook which maybe and
honestly that it could and honestly I'm
gonna say it might have been like worse
than you even thought because a lot of
[ __ ] probably wasn't even never even
reported so I kind of feel well because
look at even just going back to 1888
like the Jack the Ripper murders like
the Jack the Ripper murders like they're
still famous because they were so uh
horrible but [ __ ] that was going on in
London and White Chapel like you know
slums and stuff like that in that area a
lot of that stuff
even especially if it wasn't murder or
if it wasn't really that graphic like it
wasn't evisceration like Jack the Ripper
was doing like if some prostitute got
killed or some guy that was like a
robber or something like that if he got
killed nobody was gonna do anything
about that like it wasn't going to be
like a big deal they would find dead
bodies all the time that's what I'm
saying so I kind of feel like yeah I
kind of feel like it was probably a
zillion times worse like back then just
because it happened all the time and
everyone was like ignored to it you had
to do some [ __ ] like Jack the Ripper
[ __ ] like oh I'm gonna pull all your
intestines out and string them all over
the [ __ ] room before anyone would
even pay attention which is [ __ ] up
which is [ __ ] up well the value of
human life wasn't that's what I'm saying
I kind of feel like the the way that we
value individual human lives nowadays
which is good I'm just saying that's a
good thing but I'm just saying that's a
recent phenomenon I kind of feel like
that's a more recent phenomenon back in
the day if you were poor or if you
weren't the dominant race or whatever or
if you were a male or something like
that like they only cared about young
pretty females well I kind of well that
probably still yeah kind of the case but
uh you want young pretty white girls
yeah black ones too
[ __ ] not so much like I don't know
I've written a lot about that and it's
just kind of like I feel like the ones
that really hit the meat Atlanta Ripper
yeah but a lot of people don't
they couldn't catch him but yeah
I kind of feel like the ones that are
like the serial killers and stuff like
that are the best known yeah are ones
that killed like
teenage to 20 year old white women yeah
well of course yeah yeah I mean they
were the dumb white people were the
dominant ethnic group at the time not
I'm not trying to be like controversial
I'm just saying that's that's generally
the serial killers everybody remember
that's the victim yes if you killed
dudes or if you killed black women or if
you killed indigenous women or if you
killed prostitutes or if you killed poor
people or something like that people
might know about it but it's like not as
much well there's some crossover there
because back in the day killing black
women and killing prostitutes usually
was the same thing back in back in the
day that that was happening because the
ones that were dying were black
prostitutes they were at the top of the
list for murders
not the Atlanta Ripper though not the
Atlanta Ripper but the cops knew about
that one those women when we were trying
those women were not prostitutes I know
that they were just they were mostly
like maids and people that worked at
restaurants but they were trying to find
that dude they never could find him he
was a black offender yeah and he was he
was the black they you know because some
victims survived it was the black
Jack the Ripper I said Jenny killed more
people yeah than Jack the Ripper yeah
and did some Jack the Ripper [ __ ] too
like cut one of the girls hearts out
like one of the women's hearts out yeah
I said Jenny that'd be a badass book you
write that [ __ ] fiction would make a
whole movie called black the Ripper
it'd be like it'd be like a black
exploitation Jack the Ripper that [ __ ]
would have [ __ ] sold all kinds of
money back in the 70s if you'd come up
with a movie like that back then but you
weren't born
no I wasn't you weren't born you could
have made all kinds of money
if I was like three yeah
yeah but no that was that would have
been a cool ass move who is this
what are you talking about oh okay yeah
I talked about it that was about that
was right yeah I thought that was a new
one thank you very much to the super
chats people yeah super chats are active
he's trying to like trying to make money
John Gore said a lot of black on black
crime throughout the ages was hard as
hell to prosecute due to lack of
cooperation with the police yeah yeah
and I kind of feel like yeah and I kind
of feel like that happened a little bit
to a small extent with the Atlanta
Ripper case as well because I think that
even nowadays I did a whole video about
it on my crime and Memorial Channel if
you haven't subscribed to that but they
couldn't even agree on whether this was
one serial killer or not I kind of feel
like I don't know if all the crimes that
occurred during that time period like
during that couple year period where all
that serial killer but I think a
significant portion of them Atlanta
Ripper was this was an interesting case
me and Jenny B we were walking we would
do our walks talking about new projects
and we were talking about that one and I
just thought that would be a [ __ ]
great story
to have done but there isn't much on it
but there's like one book about it yeah
and what's what's weird is that nobody
knows about the Atlanta River and he and
and whoever he was he was a young tall
evidently good looking
black male in a [ __ ] trench coat that
could leap over a [ __ ] tall
fence in a single bound no that's not
that that was no that wasn't you're
thinking of some you're thinking of like
Spring Hill Jack didn't he jump over
that that was a whole other thing didn't
he jump over that fence to get away from
that girl after he stabbed her no okay
no he just ran away and he just ran away
okay yeah but uh you're thinking of
Spring Hill probably
but I just thought that'd be a [ __ ]
that was a story I thought that would
have been a great story
uh interesting case never caught the
dude they never did and he went after
good looking black and mixed
females and it was just women that were
like I said walking to work walking to
the grocery store just doing regular
[ __ ] he had Ted Bundy style tastes he
didn't like hookers he liked regular
women
that tube is going for him and the cops
knew but they just they couldn't catch
him
yeah it was yeah well and like I said I
talked about this on my video but it
took a really long time for the cops to
even admit that maybe this was the same
[ __ ] that was doing all this
stuff like for a long time
um they were kind of like oh well all
these women got killed by their
boyfriends or or something like they
they were like oh that the community
that that black community they're so
degenerate that kind of stuff happens
and like they would put like a woman
would get murdered like just walking
them from work or something and they
would put it like on the [ __ ] back
page it'd be like one paragraph yeah one
paragraph I found like newspapers from
back then it was like seriously one
paragraph well that would be that would
be the thing to do back in those days if
you were a cop because you're kind of
washing your hands of it you're like we
don't have a problem here it's just the
same old thing don't worry about it yeah
that's essentially what that's what
they're doing we're talking her
boyfriend killed her yeah yeah the end
we solved it bye yeah bye yeah because
they didn't want to look in effect tool
which is what they were well yeah and
whoever whatever they whiffed that big
time yeah whatever dude that was he was
[ __ ] toying with him
but I always kind of had him [ __ ]
picture just come kind of like a [ __ ]
Candyman type yeah somebody said candy I
can't even imagine yeah
that's how I put that's kind of how I
pictured him too yeah I would like to it
would have been great to flesh that
story out that have been a good [ __ ]
horror movie
Rebecca said I really wish you guys
would revisit many of your original
cases from like five years ago and live
show the cases and with updates if any
we could do that like a live chat yeah
we have talked about doing that because
I know there have been some like some
updates like I said I have done some
stuff on my crime immemorial case
because uh Channel because there have
been a couple cases where they've been
like Somerton man like I did a video on
Somerton man on my crime Memorial Day
because there has been like they did
identify uh provisionally the summertime
they don't know who killed him but still
but they know who he is now because we
also said that we we had such bad
Recording Technology back then our
microphones [ __ ] sucked and [ __ ]
the internet was different back then we
weren't sure exactly what what the
market was like the channel was new we
should go back
and touch up some of those old cases I
mean I could look back through this
stuff and I mean there but there's so
many cases that we haven't covered too I
would love to redo [ __ ] episode one
and talk about The Shining again oh my
God don't even start another I did a
show I know you don't watch my videos on
my other channel but I did a show on
scare Salon my horror Channel yeah about
shining versus shining I talked about
the Stanley Cooper movie yeah versus the
made for TV adaptation that Stephen King
was into I like the black guy got into
all of that kind of stuff it was like
[ __ ] 40 minutes long or something
like that I would defend the made for
team oh well I know you will I will
defend it I didn't like it but yeah I
defended that's I got into the whole
thing like on that video like I said if
you it's on there if you want to watch
it I'm just saying it's there I'm not
gonna [ __ ] I'm not gonna say don't
watch the [ __ ] Kubrick original what
are you talking about you go that is of
you have to watch if if you put a gun to
my head but like honestly I have to
watch it but if you put a gun on my I
said what's your favorite horror movie
it's either The Shining or the thing
yeah it's good too yeah yeah they're
both good and I don't know if I could
pick between them it goes kind of like
backwards to the shine but those are but
those two movies are ones that I can
just watch over and over again and I
never get tired yeah I never get tired
of
Danny Rowling said shining versus Dr
sleep film and book versions that's
actually I might do that because I do
like doing uh honestly if you've been
following my scare Salon I just put up
today a video comparing the book and the
movie of Stir of Echoes which was a
Richard Matheson novel which is made
into an excellent 1999 film starring
Kevin Bacon if you haven't seen it so I
did like a I think it was like 40
minutes long 35 minutes long something
like that where I compared because they
were a lot different so I compared like
the two uh things so I do like doing
like book versus movie adaptations I
never read the doctor Sleep Book but I I
saw the the movie The theatrical release
and the director's cut I liked them both
I prefer the director's cut but I liked
Dr sleep directors because it was good
good Rebecca said we should do a live
show in the Atlanta Ripper
we maybe should like I said I did one on
crime Memorial but we could yeah we
could do a live show on that that might
be fun redo it right yeah we probably
did because that was a long time ago a
long time and we we have a bigger fan
base now who listen and they you know
maybe it's time to [ __ ] retouch some
of those old cases I would like to redo
my review of Conan because it's
imperfect
the [ __ ] the way the way the dam
audio was recorded isn't that good but
we know that's that's for another time
Alex Rivera said woof that made for TV
version of the shiny what a
disappointment man go ahead no I didn't
go ahead and I don't like it either
it wasn't the yeah but that's why that's
one of the reasons I didn't like it yeah
I love the book I'm not saying that but
the book in the movie are two different
things two different things you watched
that made for TV if you haven't read the
book okay and you don't know what
happened in the Kubrick version the
Kubrick version is accurate too it's
just it's just different it depends on
the point of view of the person telling
the story
that's what Wendy would have saw more or
less
is in the is in the movie but you know
now I like to I like to be for TV also
it was good
just like the book
but that's what it would have looked
like now here's the thing some people
say well yeah well they're made for TV
to stand [ __ ] sucked too
one of our listeners sent me the new
remastered version of the [ __ ] TV
stand version for [ __ ] modern
televisions
for HD and [ __ ] it looks great it's a
lot better than what they're what uh
what the VHS version of it was I like
the stand also
all right so coming back into like what
was that with that big old long delay
what was that go ahead because I was
waiting I thought you were going to keep
no no no
see okay no I'm just waiting for you to
keep talking
so all right let's get back to the case
so I can finish because we still have
like almost half the [ __ ] to do so uh
all right so at this point they pick up
these two girls they're 13 and 15. like
I said they pick them up at like a bus
stop or something like that they give
them some they're like hey want some
weed they're like yeah sure give us a
ride some place
so they say they're going to the beach
but then they start driving toward the
mountains at which point the girls are
like hey where the [ __ ] are you going we
need to get the [ __ ] out of here
so he's like no no it's fine we're just
gonna like smoke some weed I'm gonna
pull over somewhere so he pulls over in
this like suburban area and there's like
a tennis court now Leah one of the girls
like she starts to open the door but Roy
uh is like hey you're not going anywhere
and he hits her in the back of the head
he had a bag like full of lead weights
I'm assuming they're like fishing
weights or something like that so he
like hits her with that and like knocks
her out and then he gets the other girl
like um Jackie and overpowers her she
was the 15 year old and then he starts
tying up Jackie
like putting the gag on her and all this
other kind of stuff Leah like wakes up
at this point and starts to again like
try to jump out of the van at which
point like Roy like pulls her back and
like twists she's just a little girl
she's 13. and uh twist her arm behind
her back and drags her back into the van
so at this point like both the girls are
like fighting this [ __ ] uh you
know what I mean but obviously they're
way bigger so they subdued them and they
tied them up with like duct tape and uh
and various other things
so the the [ __ ] up thing about this I
don't know if this is true or not but I
did see this on like one thing they said
where they pulled over like where they
pulled over the van and there was this
whole struggle and they were tying the
girls up and then they kind of looked
out and because they had parked in this
Suburban neighborhood and there was like
a tennis court and I guess there were
people on the tennis court and some of
the people that were playing tennis
because I'm guessing this was like the
middle of the day and they looked over
there like what the [ __ ] is going on
over there like I guess it was far
enough away that they couldn't actually
see what was going on but they like saw
that there was something weird going on
so some of the like people on the tennis
court like looked over and were just
kind of like what the [ __ ] is going on
over there and so like the the murderers
were like oh [ __ ] like they saw us
and they were like okay well we need to
get the [ __ ] out of here so they crammed
the girls in the van and then gunned it
they got the [ __ ] out of there and then
sped away and then like for the next
couple days they were really worried
because they thought somebody's gonna
call the police but nobody as far as I
know like nobody at that tennis court
that saw what was going on like called
the police I guess they didn't really
think like I said maybe they couldn't
really see what was going on maybe they
just thought
they kept them for a couple days
anything of it yeah they did actually
end up uh so they drove these two girls
13 and 15 remember
they drove them out to the San Gabriel
mountains and held them captive for
almost two full days uh they basically
kept them uh bound and gagged but you
know all that time and would take turns
raping them so there was that and the
dudes slept in the van the whole time
like alongside them
and like one of them would stay awake
and like act as a lookout like make sure
that nobody was coming and [ __ ] like
that
uh one time
uh Lawrence bitticker walked Leah to a
nearby Hill and uh made her pose for
pornographic Polaroids and then returned
her to the van
and then Lawrence also asked Roy to take
a bunch of Polaroid pictures of him and
Jackie uh both naked ones and closed
ones so they're doing all these are
teenagers these are children you know
what I'm saying they're on time for
these photographs you know I no I just
walked her out there I have no idea just
to you know uh one of the things okay
now in one of the instances where
Lawrence was raping Jackie
there was also a tape recording where
surface later it was played at the trial
where he made a recording of himself
raping her and basically made her
pretend like she was his cousin
because I guess he had a thing for his
cousin yeah cousin thing okay and then
yeah
um and then was basically telling I mean
yeah this is gonna get bad I'm just
saying
uh also another thing that he did was
that uh Jackie the 15 year old he
stabbed her breasts with an ice pick and
used pliers to tear part of one of her
nipples off that was the 15 year old yep
damn
yep
so these two little girls these two
little teenagers he didn't kill him
right away no two days damn almost two
days after the torture thing yeah
torturing the whole time damn and
recorded a lot of it
yeah it's great
so uh so yeah so they're there and then
they decide oh I guess we better kill
them
so uh basically what Lawrence said later
was that um oh well we're gonna kill
Jackie quickly because she was mostly
Cooperative like the whole time they
kept her captive whereas Leah the 13
year old like kept fighting them
so they were kind of arguing it's like
oh well should we like make them die
really slowly or so like I said it's
like [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
so
um so basically
Jackie got again stuck in each ear with
an ice pick and then strangled so that's
quick
that's what that was very thought yeah
yeah
and basically uh so Lawrence kills
Jackie the older girl 15 year old
and then Leah who's 13 she's still alive
he forces her out of the van
and says you wanted to stay a virgin now
you can die a virgin and then hits her
in the head with a sledgehammer
what they didn't rape her yeah multiple
times then how is she a virgin well I'm
just saying I don't know like I don't
know maybe they just raped the older one
I'm just saying that's what he said to
her all right or that's what he said he
said to her
so he hits her in the head with a
sledgehammer like it doesn't matter at
this point Jesus Christ like all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] they did to these people
these poor girls
so then so he hits her and I have a
sledgehammer she's still alive so he
starts strangling her and thought she
was dead but then she opened her eyes
back up so obviously she was still alive
and then he just kept like bludging her
Roy did and then Lawrence kept like
strangling her until she was dead so
then they take both these little girls
and throw them over an embankment into a
[ __ ] you know into the canyon or
whatever
now
so they do this now Sunday
September 30th
they pick out another woman now some
sources call this woman Robin robek some
say that her name was Shirley Sanders I
don't know I'm sure that one of those is
probably a pseudonym and then maybe
later her real name came out but I'm not
really sure like which one her real name
is I'm just gonna call her Robin because
that's what Wikipedia said
so she was originally from Oregon but
she was actually down in Manhattan Beach
visiting her dad
now she was walking along the street
doing whatever the hell she was doing
and these two [ __ ] pulled up
beside her in their stupid rape van and
offered her a ride and she said [ __ ] no
no thank you and then they sprayed her
with mace and dragged her into the van
so both of the guys raped her in the van
but she escaped she managed to get away
now later like she reported the uh the
rape to the police but she couldn't like
because she had been maced and couldn't
see all that good uh she couldn't really
describe what they had looked like and
she didn't get a good look at the
license plate she just basically said it
was a silver [ __ ] rape van you know
and she described what happened and blah
blah so because they couldn't catch the
[ __ ] she's like all right [ __ ]
it I'm going back home to Oregon so she
went back to Oregon
so after that happened like after she
escaped Lawrence and Roy
we're like really worried that they were
gonna get caught obviously because this
victim of theirs had escaped so Lawrence
moves to Burbank uh Roy like he got an
apartment or whatever now Roy is still
living with his mom in the trailer park
now so weeks go by and like no cops come
around so they're like okay well it's
probably fine so we can probably go out
on the hunt again or whatever the [ __ ]
so they go out again on Halloween night
1979.
so they decide uh you know [ __ ] the
beach we're gonna go like kind of cruise
around some residential streets like
some of the San Fernando Valley so they
kind of go around like a bunch of like
residential streets around there
so they see this girl uh named Shirley
Lynette Ledford and usually I see her
referred to as Lynette so I'm assuming
that she went by her middle name so she
was 16 years old now she was hitchhiking
so they offered her a ride and she
accepted now they think investigators
kind of think that she accepted the ride
from Lawrence uh because she recognized
him she was actually worked as a
waitress in a restaurant around there
and Lawrence actually had gone to that
restaurant a bunch of times so she
recognized him so she didn't think it
was like a stranger she was like oh
you're that guy that comes in the
restaurant all the time so she wasn't
like afraid of him that's what they're
thinking anyway because he did actually
go to the restaurant she worked at
so she gets in the van
and literally like in the first couple
minutes she's in the Van Roy like
basically just wrestles her to the floor
of the van and they're like look this
time we're not even gonna drive to like
our secluded Mountain area or whatever
um we can just rape and torture her
right here you know why bother going all
that way
so it's like let's do it while we're on
the on the road
so they're just driving around La like
in the suburbs and [ __ ] like that so Roy
is like okay I'll drive well so Roy
drives and then Lawrence goes in the
back and starts you know doing what he's
gonna do and also turns on the tape
recorder
so yeah so the tapes from this
basically so he had taped up uh her
mouth and legs and everything like that
and uh so he takes the tape off after
because Roy is like driving around while
all of this is going on and they have
all this recording
so thank you Bryce thank you Bryce just
tuned in that's the problem with living
on the other side of the world
definitely going to listen to the rest
of this later amazing show thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much
very much yeah this is it's kind of been
a bummer but you know we're trying to
get through it
so yeah so Roy's driving around Lawrence
is like doing his thing turning the
recorder on so he takes the tape off and
then he starts like mocking her like
slapping her face like beating her like
hitting her in the face like with his
fists and stuff and it's basically like
hey say something say something and then
she starts screaming and then he's like
yeah yeah scream louder like [ __ ] like
that
so she starts screaming louder and then
he's like what's the matter don't you
like to scream he says so he's like
based and people like these tapes are
out there I don't recommend listening to
them but they are out there if you want
to hear them they're horrifying but yeah
you can hear all this for yourself
so she starts crying obviously and uh
you know keeps saying stuff like like
don't touch me don't like stuff like
that and then uh he's like oh you can
scream as loud as you want and then he
starts hitting her with a hammer
like he starts like beating her like in
the breasts like with his fists and like
pulling at her nipples with the pliers
and stuff like that uh he's also like
raping her and sodomizing her this whole
time so you know damn
um basically just like yeah I mean
man like listen to this it's it's bad
it's bad so uh yeah so she's just like
screaming and obviously saying like no
no this whole time like whatever the
[ __ ] she's doing he's hitting her with a
sledgehammer like using the pliers and
[ __ ] like that and then Roy is basically
driving around while all of this is
going on he's like yeah this girl was
just like constantly screaming from the
back of the van
so then Lawrence is like okay Roy your
turn so then Lawrence goes to like drive
and then Roy goes in the back and like
does his kind of [ __ ]
um so basically Roy says go ahead and
scream or I'll make you scream that's
what he says on the tape
and then uh she says I'll scream if you
stop hitting me and then like start
screaming and then basically he's doing
whatever he's doing so then he
um
takes a sledgehammer and starts hitting
her
in the elbows like he breaks her elbows
with a sledgehammer one or both
well the left one I think he I think he
eventually did both of them but yeah he
was just kind of he just kept hitting
her in the elbow with a sledgehammer and
she is just freaking out obviously just
like please don't hit me again please
don't hit me again and she's like he um
actually struck her
25 times in the same elbow with a sledge
Hammer consecutively and then says to
her on the tape what are you sniveling
about he says damn
and obviously she's like screaming and
crying the whole time because Jesus
[ __ ] Christ how would you even still
be conscious at that
she's been in captivity for two hours at
this point
so Roy decides he's you know done
playing with her or whatever the [ __ ] so
he's like okay so he strangles her with
the coat hanger with the pliers like
they do
um so yeah so she was strangled and then
Lawrence is like okay we're gonna
just for shits and giggles instead of
like throwing the body into a you know
into like a [ __ ] Cavern or like off a
cliff or whatever
um just to be funny we're gonna leave
her on a random lawn and we're gonna see
like what happens like in the media damn
so they just leave her they just pick a
house
somewhere in uh Sunland I think it was
in the San Fernando Valley and we're
just gonna like they just left her in an
IV patch in some random [ __ ]
front lawn just because they thought it
would be funny or they wanted to see
like what the reaction would be like I
said people like this cannot be fixed
you can't be fixed the thing is that you
look at the dudes
and these are weak little [ __ ] these
are little hoes
all right
yeah I mean
Jesus if I got a hold of those dudes
I just wish I wish
that someone would have got hold and I'm
not a like I said I'm not a big advocate
of that kind of thing but these
[ __ ] they absolutely had it
coming oh yeah yeah absolutely had it
coming no I could pacify both of those
[ __ ]
I just wish that somebody had cut little
tiny pieces off of them and like
eating them in a stew in front of their
face or something
something like just
to make them like suffer the same way
that they may tell that girl to [ __ ]
scream and [ __ ] [ __ ] man and like I said
oh wait just wait until you get to like
the [ __ ] because they made tapes of
this [ __ ] and the tapes are around like
I said don't I'm telling you right now
please don't listen to them but I mean
if you must they are on the internet but
please don't listen to them it's really
not you don't want that in your brain
but seriously
so they're like yeah um yeah just to be
funny we're gonna leave her body like
just on a random lawn so they dump her
in like an ivy bed in somebody's lawn so
somebody that's just jogging the next
morning finds her
so when they do the autopsy they feel
like obviously she'd been raped like
multiple times uh she died of
strangulation uh obviously blunt force
trauma to the face the head breasts and
the left elbow uh because he hit her
with a [ __ ] sledgehammer and uh yeah
so she had multiple fractures also
um
all of her like her vagina her rectum
everything like that had been pretty
much torn open
um because they determined later that
Lawrence had inserted pliers into her so
you know there's that
um also her left hand had a puncture
wound and a finger on her right hand was
slashed as well
now uh basically when they after these
[ __ ] got caught which I'll get
to in a bit
Lauren said when they played him the
tape and they're like look listen to
this [ __ ] tape like obviously we've
got you cold he said oh well all that
proves was that
um she consented to a threesome
and that she couldn't really take it so
toward the end because at the end of
this tape I hate to have to inform you
of this
she was begging them to kill her and so
he basically said oh well she couldn't
really take it and she consented and I
think he even said that she that they
paid her
and that
um but she couldn't really take it she
was just saying that we could kill her
so I didn't really do it but she just
like wanted us that was like the story
that he was going with and I'm just like
oh my God like I said these dudes should
have been aborted seriously
so yeah because she was on the tape
she's basically please just kill me just
kill me and yeah so he was like [ __ ] uh
Jesus Christ now I will say too that
when they found the body on the lawn the
next morning uh this was actually kind
of a big deal because this was only a
few days I don't remember how many days
it was but it was only like a few days
after they had arrested one of the
hillside stranglers Angelo buono
um which we did a show about those two
[ __ ] too but yeah so it was
only a couple days before the story was
like what the [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] is
going on so for a second I think they
thought that maybe uh that this girl was
like a victim of the Hillside Strangler
even though it was like a different ammo
but some people thought that because you
know obviously
so uh yeah now at this point so Shirley
Lynette lid for Ledford
um she was
remember how they had this whole plan
how they were gonna kill a girl of each
teenage year well at this point I you
know they were kind of like well we
[ __ ] it all up because this is the
second 16 year old that we've killed so
we're messing up our pattern or whatever
so they're like okay well we need to
rectify that we need to like find some
other girls of other ages because that
was our plan right that was our plan
problem was though
that
Roy
uh who like I said was more like the
sexual predator aspect of the equation
early on but then it seemed like bitter
kind of like took over and [ __ ] ran
with it
Roy though couldn't keep his stupid
[ __ ] mouth shut which like I said is
probably better for the World At Large
that he couldn't but for them it was not
so good
so Roy was having such a good time that
he just like couldn't stop babbling
about it
so October of 1979 which was only like a
very short time after the last crime
that they committed he starts bragging
to another friend of his who he had
known in prison now this guy I don't
know again this is like the rape victim
but I've seen this guy name two
different things I see him called Joseph
Jackson on a couple of silver sources
and some sources call him Jimmy Dalton
so I'm assuming that one of those is you
know was like a pseudonym and then later
on they found out the real person's name
was but I'm not really sure what the
real person's name was I'm just gonna
call him Joseph Jackson because whatever
that was the first one that I saw
so these two [ __ ] were friends
in prison
so Roy starts telling Joseph it's like
oh my God we did all this like [ __ ]
cool [ __ ] and he's like bragging to him
about it and he's like I was The
Mastermind I came up with all this plan
and [ __ ] you know how [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that too
so he's basically like uh told Joseph
Jackson like very very graphic details
of particularly the last murder they had
done which was uh Shirley Ledford who
was by that point was the only victim
whose body had been discovered at this
point camera girl yeah because like I
said um you know previous to that they
had killed some other girls but they had
thrown them into like a canyon they
hadn't found their body yet bodies yet
Roy also said that um oh uh other than
those five that they did there were also
three other incidents in which we had
like kidnapped or attempted to kidnap
like young women who had either escaped
or we raped them and they got away or
something like that
um and he did actually say oh one
instance we got the girl in the van and
we were we got her uh in our clutches
and we raped her but she got away
now at this point Joseph is just kind of
like whatever man you're full of [ __ ]
but then he when um Lynette ledford's
body was found he's like oh [ __ ] like
maybe there's something to this so this
guy I don't know like what he was in
jail for or if whatever kind of criminal
but at least he was just kind of like
man this is this shit's [ __ ] up so he
called his lawyer and he's like look
this [ __ ] like told me about
this and it's like then they just found
the body I think there's like some weird
chick on I'm like what should I do
so basically the lawyer's like well
maybe you should go like tell the cops
so he's like okay well I'm gonna do that
so he did to his credit he did actually
go to the cops
so uh basically the guy that was heading
the investigation uh into at least the
lead for investigation because like I
said that was the only body that had
been found at this point uh his name was
Paul Bynum now he didn't really have any
forensic evidence at this point to
support a charge like against him but he
did have Jackson's uh you know testimony
so the fact that Joseph Johnson said oh
they have a silver van
Paul Bynum says you know I remember a
rape case where the victim survived and
she described the silver van and like
two guys in a silver van and it's like
she went back to Oregon though because
she couldn't like identify the killers
so she's so he's like okay um so he
sends a guy up to Oregon it says go find
that lady again and see like what we can
see
so they send him up there with a bunch
of pictures of these [ __ ]
so she goes through the pictures and
she's like she picks out bitticker and
Norris right away that's them
she saw him on the photos she's like yep
that's them that's the guys that raped
me
so at that point uh Paul Bynum he goes
to the deputy district attorney whose
name was Steve K now he had actually he
was familiar with Norris because he had
prosecuted him on the previous rape
charge if you remember in Redondo Beach
now K was like now we have to be really
careful with this because this might be
like way bigger and we don't want to
like jump into [ __ ] if when we don't
have the evidence we really want to get
these dudes on so many books we could
like put them away forever you know what
I mean so they said okay we're gonna
like start watching them so they put
surveillance on them
so they put surveillance on them and
almost immediately I don't know how long
it was but it wasn't very long
[ __ ] Roy Norris he gets caught
selling marijuana like in the street
like openly like while he was under
surveillance back in the day yeah 1979.
so they're like okay well now we have
something to like get him on they could
we can bring him in
so a couple days before Thanksgiving
1979 they arrested him uh for a parole
violation because he was still on parole
at this point for the previous charge uh
so they're like yeah selling marijuana
obviously now they brought in Lawrence
bitticker
um on suspicion of kidnapping and raping
uh Robin robek like the the woman that
had escaped earlier now the thing about
it though was that Robin even though she
had immediately identified mug shots of
Lawrence and Roy she wasn't when they
brought them in in a police lineup she
wasn't absolutely sure that that was
them
so uh so there was kind of like some
some weird stuff there but the thing
about it though was that because Roy had
been dealing marijuana and Lawrence had
drugs when they arrested him they're
like okay well both of y'all are in are
on parole and you're both on parole
violations so they had like legal cause
to detain them
so then they search Lawrence bitticker's
apartment
they find a whole bunch of Polaroid
pictures
and a couple of those polaroid pictures
several of those polaroid pictures
showed Andrea Hall and Jackie Gilliam
both of whom they hadn't found their
bodies yet but they had both been
reported as missing earlier the same
year so obviously very suspicious
they looked they looked inside uh
Lawrence's van also the murder Mac the
rape van and they found a sledgehammer a
plastic bag filled with lead weights a
book telling how to locate police radio
frequencies
a jar of Vaseline
two necklaces uh which were later
determined to belong to two of the
victims
and a tape recording of a young woman
screaming and repeatedly pleading for
mercy and pleading for the dudes to kill
her
so at this point like Lynette lidford
ledford's mom
she had to uh come in because at this
point they hadn't found her body yet but
uh but the thing about it was that the
mom came in and like Jackson said yeah
they said that they killed her so they
knew to call This Woman's mom can you
imagine
if you were a mom and your daughter like
you got called into the police thing and
you had to listen to a tape recording of
your daughter of your daughter being
horribly raped and tortured and murdered
I can't imagine
what the [ __ ] that would be like I think
that's what's kind of haunting me about
this [ __ ] I can't imagine they made the
woman do it
Jesus Christ this is like oh my God this
is like freaking me out okay so so she
had to come in and identify the voice
it's like say yeah that's my daughter's
voice you know what I mean and the two
and it's bad enough that that was
happening but like the two dudes on the
tape are basically like just mocking her
and making fun of her and like laughing
or saying hey scream [ __ ] and like that
kind of [ __ ] you know what I mean so
having to listen to that I can't imagine
I can't imagine I mean that woman must
be [ __ ] she must have nervous to
steal having to listen to that she must
have nightmares like forever well she's
gone now they're all dead bro I mean
yeah the thing about it so yeah
so so they identified her voice like her
mom did and then like they identified
like the two dudes voices like obviously
that's YouTube Chuckle [ __ ] voices
they also found in Lawrence's motel room
that he was staying out when they caught
him they found thank you Emily I love
listening to y'all on YouTube been
benching you guys on movie
retrospectives and full episodes well
thank you thank you very much I think
this is the first time we've seen you in
the live chat yeah but thank you very
much for showing up yeah thank you very
much for the Super Chat
yeah Rebecca said the mother would live
a horror movie type life having that in
her mind and heart forever that's what I
mean I can't imagine I can't imagine
like what that would be like you would
never
be able to forget about that you would
never be able to shake that it's just
the rest of your life how'd the cops let
her listen to that
well I guess like I said they had to I'm
sure they weren't happy about it but
it's just like edited it maybe they did
I'm not sure I'm not sure I mean I would
hope they did I would hope they only
just played her enough to like let her
identify her daughter's voice but it's
just like Jesus Christ but the thing
about it
we'll get into it later because the the
tapes got played at the trial yeah so
you know so there was that uh so yeah so
while they were searching Lawrence's
motel room where he was when he was
caught they also found seven bottles of
acid and they discovered that by talking
to these two [ __ ] faces like later on
that it's like oh that was what we were
gonna use for our next hunt with it's
like that was a new thing a new wrinkle
they were introducing they were maybe
gonna pour acid the people or like make
them drink acid or something it was just
like some new like little aspect of the
game that they were playing and that was
going to be their next thing so they had
it all in stock
great so yeah so thankfully uh they
caught them before that happened
they also found in Roy's apartment a
bracelet that had that he had taken from
Lynette litford ledford's body as a
souvenir uh they also found in both of
their houses uh 500 Polaroids more than
500 Polaroids of teenage girls and young
women uh most of which taken at Redondo
Beach Hermosa Beach and uh some that
were taken by Lawrence at Burbank High
School so a lot of these uh photos had
been taken obviously without the girl's
consent they were just kind of like
stalker kind of pictures so it was just
like at the beach to take pictures right
and they're just like taking up pictures
of girls and [ __ ] like that so yeah
that's that's fun
now at this point sir Roy Norris uh he
actually waved his right to council and
kind of like went back and forth the
interrogators for a little while at
first he basically like look I you know
I don't have anything to do with any of
this but when the authorities like
showed him like look [ __ ] we have like
so much evidence like look at all of
this and then he's like okay
um yeah well I did do it but uh Lawrence
made me
basically is how he decided he was going
to play it I didn't really want to go
along with it but I was afraid of him
and he had saved me in prison and I felt
like it was obligated and blah blah blah
blah he came up with this whole like
prison code thing and it's like I
thought he was gonna kill me if I didn't
go along and then it's like I think even
the cops back then were just kind of
like bro that is that is such [ __ ]
so but
so but he did confess so both guys did
get uh arrested and they both got
charged with five counts of first degree
murder plus a whole bunch of other
charges man like kidnapping robbery rape
deviant sexual assault which I'm
assuming uh meant the uh you know the
sodomy and also criminal conspiracy
because they had kind of like uh
colluded to do this kind of stuff uh so
Roy was the first one to be like oh
Lawrence made me do it but Lawrence
pulled the same [ __ ] too it's like oh no
Roy was the instigator and all this kind
of you know what I mean so they get
caught and then they cry you know what I
mean it's like [ __ ] I wasn't yeah I
wasn't the one that did it wasn't my
idea he made me do it but so they both
[ __ ] did that Jesus Christ
um we've talked about that before it's
like it's bad enough that you do this
kind of crap and then but then once you
get caught what you're probably going to
eventually and then you try to try to
like
a lay blame from yourself like is that
oh wasn't me it's like I I didn't do it
they made I heard the testimony of a
[ __ ] uh cop who uh he might have been
federally I don't know if he's FBI or
whatever
who was interviewing the Green River
Green River Killer [ __ ] Gary Ridgeway
and he said what impressed him the most
about
Ridgeway was how weak he was
he was weak and fearful
in police custody
which that's just how those guys are and
that's kind of the thing I kind of feel
like I don't know if it's that they
think that they're so smart or cunning
that they're never gonna get caught
it doesn't occur to them that they'll
get caught or
they're so uh uh arrogant or they're so
up themselves as they would say in the
UK that they really think that it's just
kind of like well I can just do whatever
I want and then they're just kind of
like when they get caught they're like
what do you mean this isn't okay or
I don't I don't really know what no they
know what are they thinking what are
they thinking they know it's they know
nobody uh agrees with what they're
because a lot of them they get caught
and they just start crying like [ __ ]
yeah they're [ __ ] yeah which is like
they're still slight against these girls
that they killed it's just that those
girls who are physically a lot smaller
and younger you know what I mean well I
kind of feel like that's why girls like
this pick on little bitty [ __ ]
defenseless people younger like Tina
these were teenage girls these were
grown men yeah and they were basically
snatching teenage girls yeah off the
street into their [ __ ] rape van these
were 13 15 16 year old girls well I
approved myself as an infantry Soldier
[ __ ] in the Airborne and I could
[ __ ] be a [ __ ] you know
I could be rain and nowadays I look at
I'm looking at the standards of a
[ __ ] modern Ranger and SF I was like
oh yeah be right there but in my days
back when the Army was hard I could
never be [ __ ] SF possibly a ranger if
I had good good [ __ ] luck
but I look at these dudes and [ __ ]
man
those dudes
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] all right and
only a [ __ ] [ __ ] would [ __ ]
constantly
be worried about sex and you got a
[ __ ] rape and torture a woman [ __ ]
to
to feel powerful or something it's just
some crazy [ __ ] it's it's alien to my
thinking
it just it just is it makes me mad
for me man too yeah I could never be a
cop though I could never be a cop I
don't think I could either because it's
like if I pulled in one of these songs
dude I just be like man bye and I
there's a certain part of me who thinks
well the only reason why most cops are
cops is because they're under
supervision
because [ __ ] I think of the average
dude if they were to get their hands on
this guy I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] you and
honestly to be honest like a lot of the
times I'm not a big fan because I know
like a lot of cops and some cops are
serial killers too like you know ex cops
and stuff every night so because it's
kind of like a similar kind of mindset
but it's just kind of like so I don't
know I'm not a cop apologist but in some
ways one you see the worst of humanity I
get that
so you kind of get desensitized but I
don't know like I I can totally see
most of the time like most of the people
you're arrest are probably just like
fine they [ __ ] up it's like they did
some dumb [ __ ] it's like you know
they're not going to be offenders it's
just drug offenders that's minor [ __ ]
dumb they can't think they're just dumb
and it's just like or they're in bad
circumstances or whatever so I get that
but
I get too that if you had one of these
[ __ ] in your custody like it's
like man I really like I'm I'm
questioning my belief in the rule of law
at this point because it's like we know
what these [ __ ] have done it's
like would anybody really cry well if
somebody just like [ __ ] as they're
going through the system the average cop
doesn't he's not going to know the
extent of the case it's just that he
might know one part of it but no I'm I'd
be like [ __ ] I'm glad I'm not a cop
because if I were to get a hold of some
dude like this
and I know [ __ ] the full extent of
what happened
oh man I'd [ __ ] you up you know I mean
the thing about it too is like they
didn't at first because like I said
they'd only found one bot I mean one
body's bad enough but they'd only found
one body at that point like when they
were arrested yeah so it was only later
when they started confessing and then
like one of them you know what I mean so
but the thing about it so yeah so each
each one of them like tried to blame the
other one like [ __ ] you know what I
mean they did they couldn't even they
couldn't even own up to it and just say
yeah I did that [ __ ] here's the thing
about these [ __ ] they're always
worried about the body
it's very easy to break the body and to
destroy the body of a human being
what's really requires a heart is to
destroy the soul of a human being
and they didn't do that to these girls
because when they're not experts too
they're [ __ ] morons but if I got a
hold of those [ __ ] I would [ __ ]
break their souls
I put them in a small box with a with a
hole that they can't fit their head out
through and they'd be in there for
[ __ ] years
let them out for a little bit hose them
off and I put it right back in that box
and [ __ ] when I got done with them
they'd be soulless [ __ ] Machines of
pain
and suffering their lives would be hell
I mean like I said I'm not usually an
advocate of that but people like this
very very small percentage I kind of
feel like they probably had that coming
Tom Ross version of the Mongolian death
coffin you know I've thrown this because
I feel like they didn't suffer enough I
mean they were in prison they were in
prison yeah you know but they both died
of natural causes like they lived like
they lived into their 70s they only died
recently I don't understand that and
it's like what state was this
um it was California or Oregon yeah [ __ ]
that California I think yeah but that's
the thing well yeah we'll get into like
why that happened but yeah we'll get
into why that happened so yeah so both
of them try to like blame each other
right so uh basically Roy says oh man I
was like so high on drugs most of the
time I didn't know what was going on and
like you know Lawrence made me do all
this stuff and I didn't you know I was
so high that I couldn't resist him and
blah blah
but then they played the audio tapes
which obviously showed Roy like
participating right alongside
um you know so there was that so later
on he basically had to say and this is a
this is a a quote he said that doing all
the um the torture and humiliation and
stuff like that of to the victims he
said oh we just did that quote unquote
for fun
great like I said that is why I mean
these people just are not these are not
human beings now he's supposed to talk
about putting their souls into other
clones while you're [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah I would [ __ ] I would just go for
some anxious [ __ ] like the old [ __ ]
Mongolians used to do [ __ ] look at
him look up a Mongolian death coffin
that's what I would do
and I can make that worse I can play
with their [ __ ] minds other than when
they would [ __ ] regret the day they
were ever born if I was there Satan
because I would be the devil in charge
of their hell it would be hilarious
though and I would record it
just like they did to their victims
you know I'd record yeah I mean I kind
of feel like in this case and like I
said in very rare cases because I'm not
usually an advocate of that because I
don't really think it's all that
effective but in cases like this
maybe that's the only thing that these
dudes like dudes like this understand
like you'd have to do the same thing to
them God yeah because they're they're
[ __ ] animals to begin with you gotta
do don't insult animals yeah no no
that's right animals are much better
than this animals are much they're much
cooler they don't mouth they don't do
this kind of [ __ ] no they don't animals
don't do this animals are very
understandable they're very
understandable either they're eating
another animal they're just trying to
get some food and having fun that's what
I'm saying they're not doing this kind
of [ __ ] right here so don't insult
answers they're not making some [ __ ]
pain and violence and fear and sex all
together you know this is malfunction
[ __ ] Big Time evil Big Time evil so yeah
so yeah so they're blaming each other
blah blah so now remember how I said
that they found like over 500 Polaroids
found in both of these [ __ ]
Apartments
now of the Polaroids that they found and
I'm assuming that some of them were of
the same person so it's not 500 separate
victims but it was 500 pictures and I'm
assuming that some of them were the same
person now they did actually find 60 of
the women that were in the photos and
they were fine they were so alive so
that must have been when they were doing
their practice run where they were going
around taking pictures hey we're hey
let's take your picture and blah blah
and they were doing that and then they
kept the photos so those girls were
still alive however
they also found
19 of the women that were in the
pictures
as women that had been reported missing
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
these two [ __ ] faces killed those girls
somebody else might have killed them or
they might have been runaways or a
million other things
but
19 it seems significant that 19 of the
pictures of the girls that they found
were like were missing people
just saying yeah I'm not saying they did
it
although John says I'm not against a
death penalty but I don't think Society
should be getting involved in cruel and
unusual problems I agree I agree but
cases like this I'm not Society okay
this because this these two
[ __ ] are this is Way Beyond The
Pale Way Beyond you're thinking in terms
of society and a system I'm not we're
not I'm talking about me
I would do it hell yeah [ __ ] Society
Society is going to bring Justice right
but I will bring just what we're talking
about though society as a whole like I
said 99 of the cases yeah that wouldn't
apply why would you even do this I said
the only reason that I'm even thinking
about it is because of the egregious
nature not only the egregious nature of
what they did but because they really
didn't seem to give a [ __ ] no they were
just they just thought it was hilarious
this can only be handled by a person
like me like me or in Jan Jenny could be
my advisor during this
because in cases like it's going to be
nice I could come up with waves nice and
slow like I said we're not gonna just
I'm not out to destroy the body I'm
about to destroy the soul of that person
there would be no soul left
it would be a Mindless jellyfish when I
was done
and [ __ ] I've learned from the North
Koreans and the weird [ __ ] that they do
in their camps and everything I've
listened to all the survivors of these
horrible things I understand [ __ ] the
[ __ ] that we went through in the old
army in weird and [ __ ] extreme
situations I understand endurance and
[ __ ] psychological [ __ ] torment
and [ __ ] pain I understand it
personally now and I would give my gift
of knowledge to these men they would not
be the same when I was done with them
okay it was beyond all judgment this
would be from God
I worried about [ __ ] society
but yeah so we don't know if uh these 19
particular women that were found like as
you know in pictures of them as
Polaroids in these [ __ ]
apartments and were also reported as
missing people I don't know if they
killed them or not they didn't admit to
it
um but something else might have
happened to them they might have been
runaways there might have been a million
other things but it does seem very
suspicious
so they did find one in particular that
was like an unidentified uh white woman
and the picture was very very similar to
what had been done to
um to Andrea Hall and Leah lamp and uh
Jackie Gilliam uh you know the
circumstances in the picture looked very
similar so they're not really sure if
that they don't know who she is like she
hasn't been identified as far as I know
um yeah so they don't know if these
[ __ ] also killed like more
people than they let on that's why I'm
saying that yeah they were convicted of
five but
and that's all they admitted to but that
doesn't mean that's all they killed I
kind of feel like maybe they killed more
and just for whatever reason like didn't
admit it because they did go around
taking pictures and some of those women
are they still don't know where they are
so you know
so February 1980 Roy uh he's his [ __ ]
ass is trying to get out of the death
penalty
so he says well if you give me a deal
where you know do you take the death
penalty off the table then I will not
only testify against Lawrence but I will
also show you where we dumped the bodies
because as I said they'd only found one
at this point
so he takes the authorities into the San
Gabriel mountains and shows them where
they dump the bodies now they did
actually end up finding the bodies of
Leah lamp and Jackie Gilliam the 13 year
old and the 15 year old that had been
killed uh but they never did find the
bodies of uh Cindy Schaefer their first
victim or Andrea Hall their second
victim even though he took them to the
place where they dumped it but they
never did find them you know for
whatever reason it had been like a while
at this point like probably like a year
or more but they did find a couple of
the bodies so that was enough
um so they're like okay fine you can
have the plea deal uh you know you won't
get the death penalty because you showed
us where some of the bodies were
so Steve K one of the guys that was
working on it he's like okay I would
really have liked to get the death
penalty for both these [ __ ] but
uh since Roy kind of helps them out
uh they said okay we'll give you life
sentence with parole eligibility uh in
return for your testimony against
Lawrence bitticker
so basically what they have to do I
guess at the time like the law in
California like before uh you got a
sentencing recommendation you had to
have like this big report like a
psychiatric kind of thing and like a
parole officer to talk to you and blah
blah
so whoever it was that came and talked
to Roy noted uh that Roy was very quote
unquote casual and unconcerned as he
talked about the five murders he didn't
uh show any remorse or anything like
that it seemed like just [ __ ] Monday
morning to him
uh also the uh the parole officer that
talked to him said and this is a quote
he appears compulsive in his need and
desire to inflict pain and torture upon
women the defendant himself acknowledged
that in the commission of rape upon a
woman it was not the sex that was
important but was the domination of the
woman in considering the defendant's
total lack of remorse about the plight
of the victims he can realistically be
regarded in his extreme sociopath whose
depraved to grotesque pattern of
behavior is beyond Rehabilitation that's
somebody said that that's a quote the
magnitude of the enormity of the
defendant's heinous nightmarish criminal
behaviors beyond the comprehension of
this officer that's what he said he's
talked to the [ __ ]
so at that point because Roy Norris had
got a plea deal he got sentenced to 45
to life with a minimum of 30 years to
serve before parole so when he got
paroled he actually technically would
have been eligible for parole in 2010
but when 2010 rolled around they were
like [ __ ] no no so they left him in he
died in prison a spoiler alert uh he
actually ended up dying of natural
causes at the California medical
facility in February of 2020 so he died
like fairly early [ __ ] them dude yeah
now Rebecca says oh my God Tom admitted
being The Punisher yeah oh yeah yeah
pretty much I'm bigger than him that
[ __ ] he's too small
okay so basically so let's talk about
this tape for a second so one of the
things that they and they actually
played the tape the whole tape at the
trial and it's 17 well at least a 17
minute section of this audio tape uh
particularly
um Lynette ledford's abuse and murder
now they found this tape in uh
Lawrence's van obviously
and he said Roy said that Lawrence after
they did the murder like before they got
caught he would sometimes drive around
in the van listening to the tape because
he thought it was quote unquote real
funny
he thought it was real funny and he
would drive around like listening to it
over and over again
so the elbow girl
yeah okay yeah they thought it was funny
yeah actually yeah I haven't heard it
but now I can tell you this it's just
not funny
uh it's absolutely not funny like please
don't listen to it seriously it's not
you heard it you heard something yeah
it's not it's not funny yeah not at all
hey man it would make me mad it did it
made me mad because that's probably why
I'm like really mad about the Smoky case
like I get mad about all these but I'm
really mad about this in particularly it
would make me a man yeah that's really
not I can't I [ __ ] I got the same
superpowers The Punisher the head
injuries and everything that's why I'm
not in service [ __ ] [ __ ] we made me
mad and I'd [ __ ] try to find him and
that motherfucker's dead so then I try
to find somebody who's like it it's like
no I don't want to hear that I gotta
[ __ ] be I gotta keep myself [ __ ]
safe
so here's the thing they played the tape
at the trial
um there was some some kind of
controversy over like do we really want
to like play this for the jury or
anything like that now Steve K even
though it should be noted Steve K who
was uh working on the case he actually
broke down crying a couple that like
many people did in the courtroom people
cried people walked out it was [ __ ] up
it was a whole thing
Steve K was working on the case you know
who had worked on a lot of these cases
he actually broke John crying a couple
times like during the tape but he argued
that they should play it he said uh they
asked him it's like hey is this a good
idea and this is a quote you're damn
right it should have been played the
jury needs to know what these guys did
he wanted everybody to hear it even
though it was [ __ ] up and it was
horrible and like I said people were
crying and walking out and all kinds of
stuff and it was like the worst thing
ever so but they did play it
and so it's [ __ ] up because like a lot
of people the parents were there and
[ __ ] like that I mean everybody was
crying it was awful so
um so yeah
now so Lawrence though he didn't really
seem all that concerned like before the
trial took place he thought that he was
the big [ __ ] he's like I'm gonna rate my
Memoirs like anybody want to read that
[ __ ] yeah so his Memoirs are called The
Last Ride
yeah riding around in his [ __ ] rape
van I'm assuming uh so yeah so he wrote
that I didn't read that because [ __ ]
that dude but yeah
um basically his attorney said please
don't do that but um you know you're
just handing them whatever because
you're writing all the [ __ ] he's like no
I want everybody know what I did he's
[ __ ] proud of it so he writes the
[ __ ] Memoirs and finishes them like
before the the trial the trial
he's like oh well Roy was The Mastermind
behind this it'll be fine though the
jury will will buy it like that Roy was
the man yeah and they'll find yeah I'm
like yeah how delusional are you eating
[ __ ] yeah that didn't work out
uh and actually he testified on his own
behalf which usually lawyers will tell
you in this situation like this please
don't do that prizes Lord I tell him to
go ahead on all of that
yeah go ahead maybe his lawyer did Loki
it's just like yeah yeah fine yeah
they'll totally believe you yeah okay
yeah they're gonna let you off good you
[ __ ] nutcase you'll win yeah yeah so
he went on I he seemed to be genuinely
convinced because he was a delusional
[ __ ] face that oh everyone will think it
was Roy and not me all right yeah that
didn't work out uh yeah so he testified
his own behalf he's like I didn't know
anything about that
um you know I and all of the stuff like
all the pictures and stuff oh that was
all consensual like I paid those girls
to pose for those pictures and blah blah
you know
nobody nobody bought it nobody bought it
of course not that was kind of like the
whole [ __ ] thing that he had that it
was all yeah so uh February 1981 he got
sentenced to death uh found guilty five
murder counts 21 other felonies
now the thing about it after he was put
on death row like he was never executed
but you know he died later he was little
Mr attention [ __ ] he gave like a whole
bunch of like death row interviews and
didn't feel sorry about it he seemed to
really like the celebrity I guess uh
basically he said the only remorse he
felt was that he essentially got caught
got caught yeah and it ruined his life
yeah yeah oh that [ __ ] has ruined my
life I got caught oh my God let me play
the world's tiniest violin for you right
now it ruined his [ __ ] life oh my God
wasn't this guy with the sledgehammer
well Roy did that but they both did they
both yeah they're both all right yeah
they're both culpable I just like I
don't even make a distinction between
these two [ __ ] I don't think
like oh one made the other one do it
they both wanted to do it
you know what I mean uh and the [ __ ]
up thing about this too is that yeah
Lawrence was really into I think I
mentioned this earlier but he got into I
don't know if he gave himself this
nickname or if other people in prison
gave him the nickname pliers yeah which
Jesus [ __ ] they're making fun of his
ass and well he liked it though and he's
like so he got fan mail in jail because
of course he did and he would sign the
letters that he wrote back with pliers
yeah
ugh this dude makes you just want to
throw the [ __ ] up Jesus Christ
so yeah
um
so yeah he got the death penalty but
here's another thing as if this dude
wasn't a big enough [ __ ] douchebag
so he gets put on death row
and he gets put on death row and he's
like writing letters back to his fans
calling himself pliers and all this
other kind of stuff but something else
that he did that he amused himself with
while he was in prison was that he
started because I guess at the time like
California had a law like you could like
um if you were in prison you could uh
you know file a lawsuit like without it
costing any money so he's basically I'm
gonna file every frivolous [ __ ]
lawsuit he would he kept filing lawsuits
about oh my human rights are violated
because I got a broken cookie on my
lunch tray he would do [ __ ] like that
yeah he filed 40 lawsuits costing the
state who knows how much money he
thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
he thought it was [ __ ] hilarious it's
like it's not bad enough that he killed
poor like five poor [ __ ] girls
uh you know and did horrible things to
them but it's like now that he's in
prison he's like well I'm gonna [ __ ]
be hilarious I'm just gonna like waste
all these people's money by saying it's
like oh my my human rights my human
rights like my my cookie is broken and
my food is cold and all of a sudden he
filed lawsuits like that oh my God this
dude should have been killed at Birth
but yeah he wasn't unfortunately so yeah
it's just kind of like yeah so he kept
doing that
all the [ __ ] got thrown out obviously
um so yeah so he gets a death penalty
but he kept appealing he kept like
filing all these [ __ ] a lot [ __ ]
lawsuits stuff like that so they set the
initial execution date for actually
December 29 1989 but he appealed that of
course because that was kind of his
thing and uh but the U.S Supreme Court
in 1990 were like no [ __ ] kill his
ass they upheld it uh but then it got
renewed again and then they were like
okay no we're gonna kill him on July
23rd 1991 and then he appealed that one
and then so he got to stay and then they
kind of pushed it back again so they
kept pushing it back
so I don't know like I said it was just
kind of like he just wanted to be a big
pain in the ass and he just kept doing
this and it should be noted too Not only
was he filing appeals to get his [ __ ]
death sentence pushed back and filing a
bunch of stupid frivolous lawsuits that
were wasting all this [ __ ] taxpayer
money like about broken cookies and
whatnot but he also hung out with other
dudes that were in prison at the same
time who were also serial killers some
of whom were Douglas Clark William bonan
Randy Kraft they had a whole serial
killer card game [ __ ] situation going
on and he was like hanging out with that
meanwhile California taxpayers American
taxpayers are paying for this
[ __ ] to like do all the
[ __ ] and he just thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious that he raped and
killed like all these teenage girls
great great so it was that so
great I'm glad this [ __ ] dude is dead
I kind of wish he had suffered more
before he died because he was on death
row
and you know how long it takes because
they have all the appeals and they never
get around to it blah blah so he
actually ended up dying of [ __ ]
natural causes I hope it was ass cancer
but he died in uh at San Quentin
December
2019 so he was in prison all that time
playing cards with his other serial
killer buddies and filing lawsuits about
broken cookies and whatnot laughing at
all of us and then he died of [ __ ]
old age like I said I hope he got
[ __ ] ass cancer and hemorrhoids and
everything every other I hope he had
arthritis in his dick and everywhere
damn [ __ ] man yeah these guys pissed me
off oh and also okay
so here's a couple little it's mostly
over but here's a couple little things
to like leave you with remember I
mentioned Paul Bynum the the chief
investigator who was uh you know the
chief investigator behind this uh case
he committed suicide in December of 1987
he was 39 years old
and in his 10-page suicide note one of
the things that he brought up as
spurring it was this [ __ ] case he
couldn't take it he had investigated
like a bunch of he's like yep I'm out
I'm out so that's how [ __ ] bad this
was and this is like we probably don't
even know all the worst details he was
an investigator he was like the lead
investigator on the [ __ ] he was 39 years
old and he's like yeah I'm checking out
of this [ __ ] if this is what the human
race is like I don't want any part of it
bye
um you know so that's horrifying you
know how bad it has to be for like a
dude to do that yeah Rebecca Dunn in the
comment section said that Farah Fawcett
died she did yeah yeah she did but I
didn't wish that on her though she
didn't deserve ass cancer this guy
deserves ass cancer if anybody fair was
cute if there was if there was a God if
there was any justice in the world then
dudes like this would get ass cancer and
suffer for years and years and years and
nice people wouldn't get it Farrah came
off as dumb as rocks but she was cute
dumb as a box of Rock
yeah
so yeah not not only did the lead
investigator
on this case commit suicide at 39
because he couldn't [ __ ] take it yeah
and I think I alluded to this earlier
but the audio tape uh of the rape and
torture and murder
of uh Shirley Ledford Lynette Ledford
uh is and I don't know if this is true
or not but they they still have it in
the FBI Academy and that is one of the
things that they play uh for aspiring
FBI agents to kind of desensitize them
or at least say hey this is the kind of
[ __ ] that you're going to be
investigating so if you want to opt out
you might as well do it now because this
is like the worst of the worst I don't
know if that's true or not I don't know
if they still do that
but from what I know they do use that
tape as like a training exercise saying
this is something that you might
encounter so if you're gonna if you're
not gonna be able to handle it then
maybe this isn't the job for you Jake
Adams says oh and I meant to mention
this too
Scott Glenn who uh was in Silence of the
Lambs he actually listened to these
tapes as training like he's an actor
obviously as training for this uh movie
and uh he did not uh he did not like it
he was just kind of like yeah yeah
Bailey said Scott Glenn hated the
director for recommended listening to
those tapes I mean I'm sure it probably
like informed his role but it's one of
those things that
you you can't like get it out of your
head so you always have to kind of like
think about it ahead of time like do I
really want this in my brain forever
like for the rest of my life yeah you
know and I kind of feel like it's that
so you can say that it's kind of shitty
and I don't even know if the FBI got
permission from like the victim's family
member I'm assuming they probably had to
but it's like Federal that's what I'm
saying like did they and that seems kind
of shitty like I don't know I can see
both sides yes it is very shitty like
using like if that was your daughter and
like you think that they're training FBI
agents with a bunch of like random
strangers are listening to your
daughters like horrible rapists don't
need permission to do that that's what
I'm saying but I can but on the other
side of it I can see why they do that
too because they're just kind of like
look this is one of the worst things
that you're ever likely to encounter if
you can't handle this then maybe this
isn't the job for you because you might
encounter something like this you know
all right so you all got any kind of
questions or anything you wanted to ask
for me and Jenny are checking off
because looking I'm gonna uh I can go
down and I can make it something to eat
you want some crab salad or would you
rather have a pizza I got dough made up
and everything
oh gosh both things sounds really good
does it sound good because Victor just
got here Vicky you want to show up this
late in the [ __ ] game we've been on
for four hours damn it's just this is
over bro
Tammy says uh great show Jenny thanks
for going down this dark and gruesome
hole for us
I mean yeah yeah and I mean like I like
I said I'm to an extent I'm pretty
desensitized because I write about this
stuff all the time I see this stuff all
the time and it's just kind of like you
know I'm not a cop or anything like that
but I read enough about it I see enough
about it that I'm just kind of like okay
I don't like it but but this case
I don't know I think what pissed me off
the most about this
was not only the extent of the [ __ ] that
they did but the fact that they just
thought it was funny the thought that
they thought it was funny and they were
like willing to say in front of other
people yeah that tape was like funny and
they weren't even being like edgeable I
don't know maybe they were being Edge
Lords or whatever but it's like you know
how much I hate Ed shorts but I kind of
feel like they were just kind of like
yeah whatever no they didn't give it
that's hilarious and it's just like that
oh that just enrages me that enrages me
that's why I'm I I'm more like [ __ ]
uh
like like a [ __ ] paranormal stuff
this stuff makes me mad
you know it makes me mad too but yeah
the weird thing about it is like it
makes me mad but
I don't know it also kind of like it
interests me more than the Paranormal
stuff because paranormal stuff I'm just
kind of like ambivalent about because
I'm like maybe that exists or maybe it
doesn't but like the True Crime [ __ ]
that absolutely does exist and I'm
always and I'm fascinated by
uh the psychology behind it like I said
I think the thing that enrages me the
most is just that I don't understand
people that can do this kind of [ __ ] and
like just think it's funny or like not
have any feeling one way or the other
about it that like blows my mind and I'm
and that so it fascinates me I'm
disgusted by it but it fascinates me at
the same time and I think a lot of
people are in the same boat I mean if
if the popularity of True Crime [ __ ] is
any indication in that regard I kind of
feel like a lot of people are fascinated
and I think that a lot of people are
fascinated for that very reason because
they're just like this is like an alien
mindset yeah like why would you do we
talked about that earlier like some
murders I get it like I don't condone it
but I get why it happened like it wasn't
that crazy or that weird like it's
understandable because oh you like you
know you got mad like I said somebody
was cheating on you or something like
that or somebody [ __ ] you over or
something like then you got mad and like
killed them like I get that but this
kind of [ __ ]
like you do in that like this
calculating
like let's build a van
we're gonna build a van we're gonna put
all we're gonna kid it out and then like
go and just snatch girls off interesting
people it's just people you don't even
know they're just like rain is the thing
that blows me away innocent people that
are not a threat
you know what I mean that that blows my
mind
that that's not a military type
situation you know I mean just not good
I mean I can understand a mass of people
that might be a threat in the big
picture
but an individual person who is not a
threat and this is and the motive is
sexual nah
nah I just can't mentally do that and
the fact that they could just do that
coldly and then like laugh over hours
and days and then they get caught later
and then they're just like yeah that
[ __ ] was funny whatever it was good
whatever they weren't people they're not
people these dudes are not real people
they're I yeah I kind of feel like maybe
maybe not because something is
definitely missing so I think he's
definitely missing a big like I said
[ __ ] anytime [ __ ] I was ever
involved in any kind of violence there's
a goal behind it you know and there's a
bigger picture
it's just never it's just you know
you're trying to protect
people or things that you care about
you know what I mean and um but the
thing is there has to be empathy there
was always empathy for this enemy
their look seeing things from Another
Side it's like professional sports when
you're in the army
just like all these middle easterners
and stuff
civilians back home did not couldn't see
things through the Iraqi eyes or The
Afghani eyes they just saw
guys like me as Invaders
you know what I mean yeah too if the
situation something invented my country
I'd be doing this you wouldn't see this
yeah that's what I mean so you have to
have some kind of like well that's what
empathy means you can put yourself in
someone else's shoes if I was that
person how would I be seeing this
situation they're telling us we're going
to bring them democracy they don't want
that [ __ ] they want [ __ ] their they
want Islam and they're religion it's a
difference of opinion but I totally
understand what they're talking about
and then like as time goes on you find
out on our side you know that you know
this is what they told us you know a lot
of this [ __ ] when you really get down to
it in the professional soldiering
business is about money and power of the
people that are far above you up in the
damn food chain which is it's all a
problem man it's all a problem it
shouldn't have finished no that should
have should have happened okay
I'll [ __ ] hang out with you my
family's deeply [ __ ] involved with
the Middle East going back to my
grandfather and [ __ ] you know
um both my granddad my grandmother and
[ __ ] all my aunts and you know came
they lived in Isfahan Iran during the
[ __ ] 70s working for the shaw all
kinds of crazy [ __ ]
the Middle East and everything is not as
[ __ ] different from the from the West
as you think
you know what I mean it's just a story
that they tell you like I said people
around the world are pretty they're
pretty much the same the reason people
are fascinated with serial killers all
over the world they're not the same it's
because they are not they're not the
same they're like animal they're like no
they're not animals not animals they're
animals empathy they're like Monsters to
a degree yeah more like an insect
a parasitical insect which you're like
how could a human be like that
that's what I'm saying yeah I think
that's what enrages me it enrages me
because I know that there's nothing that
I could do about it there's nothing I
could say to these guys that would get
through to them yeah and to me that's
very because I'm a very reason based
person and most people are like pretty
open to that like like I said most
people are okay most people are normal
human like they have empathy like to a
degree but when you encounter somebody
like this there's absolutely nothing
that you could do or say to somebody
like this that would make them realize
the enormity of what they were doing
um they just don't give a [ __ ] and that
freaks me out that like that enrages me
and I and I can't like I and I have like
all of this emotion about it and I can't
like direct it you know what I'm saying
Sebastian sent us five pounds thank you
Sebastian thank you Sebastian um [ __ ]
um hold on what I was gonna say Victor
we're we did spooky shows man we're
doing [ __ ] we're doing an extra
um uh uh [ __ ] uh ghost show every
week we're doing a haunting we're doing
it every Monday so every Monday and you
know
I mean you guys said we you want a more
paranormal stuff and we like doing a
haunting yeah so those are fun to do so
we do those every month we'll do as much
as you guys ask for if you want to do
more of that we can we can and like I
said I usually what I try to do if
you're on if you're not on our patreon
go join our patreon but on the patreon I
put up five different topics every
single week that you guys can vote on
yeah this is the one that won this week
the toolbox Killers so I usually try to
put a good combo of some paranormal
topics some true crime topics some weird
history topics I usually try to like
have a good mix in there like a good
variety so I can gauge what people are
feeling more for that week and I kind of
feel like last week we did Paranormal
because we did haunted pubs right now
the week before that we did True Crime
because we did the Acid Bath killer but
I kind of feel like we've done like a
lot of paranormal shows like in the last
because I kind of feel like in
July almost all the shows were were
either paranormal or were like more like
weird history [ __ ] than like True Crime
I don't think we did any true crime in
July I can't remember but
so it just seemed like this this time
around it seemed like more True Crime
stuff was getting more votes so that's
what we did I personally and I'm not
like trying to influence anybody I
personally
um I don't know if I want to say Enjoy
that's not the word that I want to use
but
I like the True Crime shows better uh
just because that's more in my
wheelhouse and I uh it's easier for me
to research stuff like that the
Paranormal stuff is a little amorphous
and it's usually harder for me to
research and you know a lot of it is
kind of like I don't know like the True
Crime shows they're not more fun for me
necessarily because they usually just
like make me angry and stressed out like
this one did but the Paranormal ones are
like less I don't know they're more
stressful for me because it's more
amorphous like I said it's it takes
longer to research and blah blah blah
the True Crime ones are easier in that
regard but yeah harder emotionally I
guess if that makes any sense I don't
know but you want pizza sure let's get
pizza go ahead and shut it down Jenny go
ahead and shut it down we'll see you
guys Victor said we need a show about
grits you want to show about grits I
mean you [ __ ] are always talking
about [ __ ] grits as pretty as grits
are we should do a whole I just I
subscribe to a [ __ ] Channel called
react to stand and it's some tribal
Pakistani people reacting to [ __ ] and
two days ago they gave him shrimp and
grits oh my God they [ __ ] loved that
[ __ ] well how could you not it's
delicious
those pakistanis these are tribal
pakistanis who are like this is the best
this is the best best [ __ ] ever sure the
best way of [ __ ] serving corn yeah
you know and they were going like we
understand it and they had the Cajun
seasoning and they had freaking cheese
in there and they had the [ __ ] uh uh
shrimp they caught him
shrimp fishes is what they were there
was the it was the exactly they live in
the water fishes they're kind of like
fish this is like a shrimp fishes they
said these are good there's kind of
weird looking fish and um they said it's
kind of like
pureed chickpeas
that's the way they describe it light
pureed chickens they like the flavor and
they I guess I don't know why
everybody's weirded out by grits it's
like a funny name people eat polenta
right it's not that different you know
what I mean it's it's basically the same
kind of [ __ ] as like rice or polenta or
something like that it's like a it's a
black canvas book covers grits
we've had people from England [ __ ]
contact us we did the Grits they were
[ __ ] good yeah grits are very good I
got [ __ ] probably 30 pounds of
[ __ ] dried grits they keep forever
got 30 pounds downstairs like I said I
think I think people get a get weirded
out because of the name I think it's the
name more than anything like what the
[ __ ] is that it's hot it's just it's
corn it's fine yeah it's it's Corn based
you take corn
you turned into Harmony and then you
puree and you dry it turns these little
grits things that can be reactivated and
it makes like polenta uh one one uh uh
one uh guy
Pakistani guys this is it's kind of like
rice pudding
kinda is he like hot rice pudding
because they make hot rice pudding yeah
it's kind of like that like I said it's
not any different than any other like
yeah blank canvas sort of starch right
like rice or potatoes or yeah cream of
wheat or whatever it's it's just sinking
you season them to whatever you want
yeah yeah you put whatever you want in
there you can put eggs in there you put
bacon cheese some people do sweet stuff
yeah sweet you can make me sweet I don't
like them like that but some people do I
like them with salt pepper Cajun
seasoning butter cream [ __ ] cheese
hard-boiled eggs I like bacon bits I
like them with cheese and hard-boiled
eggs yeah and although I'll eat them
with just butter and pepper in them yeah
I think yeah you can do whatever you
want with them they're good it's good
but yeah good okay go ahead and shut it
down all right we're gonna have some
pizza yeah we want pizza okay yeah let's
make some pizza I mean we have a crab
salad and that sounds good too pizza
sounds good also because I'm kind of all
I've had is like one hot dog that end
was starving yeah and that was like
hours and hours ago so I'm like really
really happy she's never had him but it
happened Monday yeah you can get them
you can buy them from Supermarket uh you
can get instant grits or the old or
quick grits or you can get them in a big
package uh it's up to you and so the the
instant grits a lot of times they come
in like a little packet kind of like
oatmeal and they're already pre-seasoned
nah you want to see some of yourself I
mean those are all right okay but you
season it you said well I used to get
the plain ones and put my own seasoning
the very basic thing is you make grits
and you put some kind of cheese in it
cheddar cheese well really cheese some
cream salt pepper and bacon bits and
maybe like chives
and eat that oh hell yeah Victor says no
I'm gonna eat them at your house
we've got a lot we haven't made them in
a while but I got a [ __ ] ton of grits
grits can stay forever that got that got
Southerners through the [ __ ] Civil
War [ __ ] and all those damn embargoes
and [ __ ] you know Siege and [ __ ] we
ate grits and it became a [ __ ] it's a
whole it's a staple
grits is the American version in Mexico
grits would be kind of like
maseka or Masa to make [ __ ]
tortillas be like that not the same not
the same Tammy says shut this [ __ ] down
I'm gonna shut this [ __ ] down go ahead I
mean we've got four hours and 10 minutes
[ __ ] four hours that's good I got
through all the stuff though the full
show it was a full show all right so
thank you everybody for hanging out with
us this Wednesday evening uh thank you
for all the super chats so we'll be back
Friday night for our Infamous Sidetrack
show or we're drinking just talk about
whatever the [ __ ] we don't even have a
topic so hopefully you guys will join us
again for that so have a good rest of
your evening have a good day tomorrow
and we will see you on Friday night bye